Oh.
[Muzică]
[Aplauze]
Am ajuns la parcă. Am încărcat toate
bagajele în parcă. Mihai se ocupă să
pună Salut. Salut, Mihai! Am pregătit și
lansetele. O să pesc cu două cali cu
patru calibre. Și astea ce sunt? Trabuco
>> max deep
>> maxep
>> de 3 m. Astea sunt de pește mare.
>> Gata, dragi pescari, am pornit la drum.
Chilia. Cinci zile pe chilia.
Șase zile în funcție de pește.
[Muzică]
Ne am oprit la poliția de frontieră.
Normal și frumos este să te oprești, să
le spui unde te duci și ce faci. Ăă, iar
domnul de aici, un domn foarte drăguț,
ne a întrebat dacă știm praseul, dacă a
mai fost. Să nu trecem pe partea
cealaltă la ucrainieni, să ținem malul
din dreapta. Așa este frumos și Cibițan.
Așa că dacă încercați să pescuiți pe
Kilivia și ieșiți pe canalul 36, opriți
vă la ei și vorbiți un pic cu ei pentru
că sunt niște oameni de nota 10.
[Muzică]
Sunt de pe brațul Chilia și la un moment
dat se desparte brațul Chilia. În partea
stângă sunt ucrainienii și în partea
dreaptă suntem noi. Și mulți pescari de
foarte multe ori au luat o în partea
stângă și au avut probleme. Așa că vă
arăt și vouă și să aveți grijă de
fiecare dată când veniți pe Chilia s o
luați prin partea dreaptă.
Ne am oprit pe Chilia. Am sondat vreo
două trei locuri. Am înădit două locuri
și acum o luăm spre obrize. Ne întâlnim
cu Marian de la Gigantiș acolo. Stau un
pic cu ei asta din bal. Uite o aice.
>> Da. Haideți să vă arăt o ciată din
n arată.
>> Arat o mă. Arat o. Niciata
noastră, băieți. Îmi pare rău, dar nu
pot să vă arăt.
Sunt niște pescari. Ne am întâlnit aici
cu niște prieteni pescari și
>> și pește.
Na, știți cum e în Delta Dunării, când
te duci pe locul cuiva, din respect, ar
fi bine să nu să nu shareuiești locul cu
altcineva pentru că data viitoare vei
avea nevoie de informații și este
posibil să nu te mai ajute nimeni.
Rămăsesem la faptul că o luăm spre
obrize, o să dormim acolo în noaptea
asta, o să înăptăm acolo, ne punem
tabăra acolo și mâine o luăm spre
cioatele pe care le am nădit. Asta în
cazul în care nu dăm de niște tramvaie
pe acolo. Nu, că dacă dăm de tramvaie,
ne întoarcem peste două trei zile, când
se taie acolo. Hai, rămâneți cu noi până
la final.
[Muzică]
În sfârșit am ajuns la obrize. Am venit
să l salutăm pe Marian Mincu de la GFT.
Prietenul nostru este cu Cipri la Bit
prin Șevști. Îi salutăm. O să îndotăm
aici pe undeva pe lângă ei și de mâine
ne întoarcem pe locurile pe care le am
nărit. Ce credeți băieți că pescuitul
este ușor în Delta Adunării? Ia spune le
tu, Mihai, de cât timp căutăm noi locuri
de pescuit.
>> Căutăm de dimineață. Hai că am nădit am
nădit vreo trei locuri.
>> Am nădit trei locuri. Am venit la
obriză. Am căutat locuri la obriză. Ne
am pus pe un loc la obrize. Nu ne a
plăcut cum ne am pus. Nici pragul nu era
ce trebuie.
scriam cumva în spatele ciatei și nu
reușeam să ne ancorăm
bine, așa că am plecat de acolo și
căutăm un alt loc. E aproape de
întunecat,
vede în spate. Dar ăsta este pescuitul.
Căutăm până găsim peștele.
>> Am reușit să ne instalăm și noi tabăra.
Bine, tabără mare taberă un cort. Am
făcut un foc, ne am pus o măsuță mică
și ne punem și noi ceva de băut, după
care ne băgăm la somn.
Am instalat lansetele, le am pus toate
pe bilet de 24, nu? Pe bilet de 20 și
Mihai are Eu am pe bilet de 20. Mihai
are pe bilet de 24.
Trei cu trei. Haideți să vi le și arăt.
Nu știu cât se vede că este întuneric.
Deci aici sunt trei pe barcă.
Da.
Și aici încă trei ale lui Mihai, dar nu
se mai vede. Ia
încă trei.
Eu unul Sunt foarte obosit.
Am
m am mers toată ziua cu barca, a bătut
vântul,
a fost
dificil, cum s ar zice.
>> Care i Care i paharul meu?
>> Ăla de acolo.
Da. Ne punem și noi un pahar. Au venit
țințari, ne am dat cu Autan. Bem un
pahar, după care ne băgăm la somn și
mâine o luăm de la capăt.
5:00 dimineața.
Ne a trezit un pește pe ran.
Am mai avut și eu un pește care a
încurcat cred că toate lansetele, dar nu
înțeleg. Cred că nu am auzit
avertizorii.
Cum e, Mihai?
>> Deși parcă se freacă de ceva.
>> Da, pare agățat.
Ți am zis că pe calibra îți vine.
>> Frumos. Ce trebuie?
Ne am mutat pe barcă
ca să poată Mihai să aducă peștele mai
bine
și o să în Unde?
>> Uite l, bă băiatule.
>> Acolo e.
>> Da. Uite,
>> mamă.
Păi la mama naibi. Dar cât fir a luat,
mă?
Poți să
>> Poți să mărești
cu zoom. Lasă ăsta.
Stai că am obosit.
Hai, Doamne ajută să l dăm afară să l
vedem că oricum eliberă.
Dar mai era un fier de agățat. Cred
>> cred că s astea ale mele.
Uite că eu am avut pește. Uite, le vezi
că le am încurcate.
>> Păi ce i ce i acolo? Un fir acolo. Cum?
>> Da.
Doamne, ce dor mi era de un dril.
Vezi că o iei pe asta din stânga acolo.
>> Ia uite ce bule scoate. Vezi?
>> Mihai
unde? Pe stânga, pe stânga.
>> Mamă, Mihai, ia uite, mă, tramvaiul.
Nu, nu, nu, nu.
Ce vorbești, mă?
Deci
>> ușurel, ușurel. Hai, tată, la poză.
>> Tramvai la 5:00 dimineața.
>> La poză, tată. Hai.
Asta dat trezire, Mihai,
>> bă, dar am dormit bine.
>> Vrei să mai iau și eu lanseta? O zic
încă nu te ai obișnuit tu cu caliberele
astea.
Oh
vrei să oprești tu filmarea și să
scoatem. Hai,
>> băieți, a trebuit să oprim filmarea
pentru că nu reușeam să l scoatem.
Ia uitați vă cât animal.
Mihai 15 plus
>> are. are are.
>> Hai să vedem. Hai să facem un pariu. Eu
zic că are 14.
Pe cât?
>> Eu zic că s are 15. Da.
>> Da.
>> Hai. Cine?
>> 14. Pe cine?
Se pune pariu.
>> Cine pierde face masă.
>> Bine, e cu dejun.
>> Hai să vedem.
Hai, Mihai, hai să l cântărim. Arată la
cameră
și hai să l și cântărim pentru că sunt
curios
imediat.
Cred că nu mai știu unde am.
Uitați mă băieți.
Vedem înte
>> în capul de minciog. Nu
>> după aia capul de minciog.
Hai să
>> Eu nu văd.
>> Ai pierdut pariul, Mihai
>> 1355.
Încă o dată.
>> Mai ridic o dată. Uite 13 5 25 că se
blochează.
>> Gata.
>> Hm.
>> Ok.
>> Deci 13 și Ia să vedem cât are capul de
minciogă.
>> Păi are vreo 500 de g.
Fraților, o să vă arăt ceva care foarte
rar vedeți în Delta Dunării.
Hai, Mihai!
Da, asta se numește eliberare.
Pește de 13 kg.
Suntem în deltă.
pe brațul Chilia.
Este 5:00 dimineața. Mihai a scos un
frumos crab de dunere
și acuma eliberează corespunzător.
Oho! Ține l, ține l un pic
să revină.
Ăla i.
>> Bravo, Mihai! Felicitări!
Mulțumesc,
>> dragilor.
Îmi doresc să văd mai multe clipuri de
genul ăsta, cum prindem și eliberăm
peștii.
>> Al doilea drill c minute.
>> Am revenit, am revenit.
>> Nici n am eliberat bine peștele și a
venit altul. Nu este mare ăsta, așa
pare.
>> Mai, mai bucură te de drill un pic.
>> S obișnuit din barcă, știi, să mi scot.
Păi poți să te duci, vrei să te duci pe
partea aialaltă să dai la tașa că scoat.
>> Stai să iau minciogul mare. Sau Da
obosește l un pic că e prea A fost în
scurt drillul.
>> Da
și ceă asta
>> e ușurel că ai lansetă
top
>> mă mă duc să iau minciogul.
>> Nu, nu, nu.
Stai așa, stai. Ai cioc
Stai, stai, stai, stai, stai, stai,
stai, stai, stai, stai, stai.
Sunt cuarele în față, dar se vede
frumos.
Oho!
Un 2 kg.
Ia hai la salat cu el.
>> Ăsta îi dă drumul la fier. Așa.
>> Ca să înțelegeți, avemuri
de mincioc pentru pește mare și pentru
pește mic.
Uite ce bătăioși sunt.
>> Da, da.
Ușor, ușor.
Eu cred că ai pește și în lanseta aia
din mijloc, din barcă, că tot se mișcă
vârful ăla.
>> Da.
Și cred că e niciodată propti ceva.
Mergem să
>> Ia uite, dragilor,
după un 13 plus, un 1 plus
>> poze nu mai facem.
>> Hai, nu mai drumul. Da.
>> Hai, da, da.
>> Revenim cu alte cap.
>> Stai că ți fac poză și de aice că pot să
fac poză și de aici.
>> Așa.
Gata.
>> Și acum o eliberăm de frumoasă.
Așa. Să să nu faci baie.
>> Nu i problemă.
>> Gata.
Să vă fac așa o mică povestioară despre
ce s a întâmplat până acum în deltă.
Luni când am ajuns toată ziua am pierdut
o pe drum. Ne am oprit la câțiva
prieteni pe apă. Doar seară am reușit să
lansăm câteva lansete la apă și marți
dimineață am luat un pește. De fapt,
Mihai a luat un pește de 13 kg.
Eu am prins un
ciortan sau cred că câți au fost, Mihai,
în ziua aia doi, trei ciortani.
>> Așa. Am stat acolo, ne am ne am campat
pe mal pe Chilia. Am stat acolo o
noapte. O noapte am stat, Mihai.
>> Hm. Am stat acolo noapte, după care am
plecat de pe de pe loc de pe locul unde
am pescuit și ne am dus în altă parte.
>> Pe Chilia, în zona
de vărsare, înspre obrize.
>> Da, spre obrize.
Am tot căutat peștele. Asta am făcut
noi. Noi n am venit să pescuim la
ciortan, am venit să pescuim la pește
mare. Ciortan s a prins, na, s a mai
prins. 1 doi pe colo, un do pe colo, dar
pescuim cu bile mari de 24. Mihai are și
o bilă de 32 pe pe o lansetă pusă. Deci
suntem hotărâți pe pește mare. Miercuri
am ajuns pe un loc pe aproape de
Tatanir. Am campat acolo. Eu am pescuit
de pe mal, iar Mihai a pescuit
și eu cu Hari și cu Sile, pentru că am
fost mai mulți pescari.
Mihai a ieșit un pic cu barca să se uite
în zona unde pescuiam noi și după a luat
o în aval și a găsit un loc unde a
pescuit pe prag.
Mihai, zi mi ce ai prins ieri ca să le
spunem să le spunem urmăritorilor.
>> Ă ieri am ajuns pe pe locul ăsta din
>> Dar întoarce te la cameră să te vadă și
>> Păi trebuie să mă uit la lansete.
>> Întoarce te că auzim
>> Ok. Ok.
Am am pescuit pe un prag abrupt de la 8
m la 11 m, un prag aproape vertical. N
am putut să mă ancorez un pic mai pe
larg pentru că bătea vântul foarte tare
și am avut cinci cinci trăsături toată
ziua. toată ziua însemnând de la ora
12:30
la 7
seara când am venit am plecat spre voi
>> și am
scos am reușit să scot doi doi crap unul
pe la 5 6 kg unul pe la 7 kg și
>> o să scuză mă un pic o să vă pun poza cu
peștele cel pe care l a prins Mihai cel
mai mare și poate vă pun și eliberarea
pentru că am eliberat peștii.
>> Așa,
bravo!
>> I am I am eliberat pe amândoi. Vreau să
vă dau și un și un sfat pescarilor care
veniți în deltă în perioada asta.
Opriți pește cât să gătiți pe mal sau în
barcă.
Nu, nu, nu rețineți
mult pește pentru că peștele
ținut în sacii de păstrare în perioada
de vară.
Deci există și vorba asta între pescari.
Mi a murit peștele. Păi, a murit din
vina ta, a a pescarului. Trebuie să
știți că peștele nu rezistă mai mult de
Nu știu. Nici nicio zi nu știu dacă
rezistă în sacul de
>> acuma acuma este foarte cald. Apa la
suprafață este caldă, nu este oxigenată
și când pui peștele și stă în sac, stă
la suprafață, el oricum, na, moare. Deci
o zi nu rezistă. Deci cel puțin din din
considerentul ăsta ne ar plăcea să vedem
în perioada asta și în Delta Dunării mai
multe eliberări dacă nu pentru plăcerea
fiecăruia de a mai și elibera din
din capturi pentru că nu rezistă măcar
asta să luăm în considerare.
>> Se întâmplă următorul fenomen: bagi
peștii mincioc, după care trebuie să i
arunci pentru că ei au murit și faci mai
mult rău. Știi de câte ori am văzut
chestia asta? Sute zeci, zeci, sute de
kilograme aruncate în perioada de vară.
>> Da. Bun, Mihai.
Hai să vorbim. Să ți povestești cum am
pierdut peștii sau asta?
>> Deci primul fiind pragul aproape
vertical
e greu și de scos plumbul când n ai
trăsătură, vrei să schimbi. E greu de
scos. De multe ori se agață plumbul
acolo. Avem și o agățătură în prag
acolo.
>> Da,
>> ai văzut?
>> Da, da, da. Ne am uitat cu sonarul și
este o agățătură. Este o creangă direct
pe prag. Așa. Deci primul am simțit că i
pește destul de mare, aveam frâna destul
de strânsă.
M a tras cu lanseta înspre larg și doar
am pus mâna pe l am ținut câteva
secunde, am pus mâna pe frână și când am
dat drumul la frână am simțit cum mi a
căzut plumbul și în câteva secunde mi a
venit plumbul în prag. Hm.
>> Am reușit să scot să scot plumbul, dar
peștele s a dus. Încă unul l am l am
pierdut în prag. Efectiv n am reușit să
s a roptit plumbul în prag. Nu știu dacă
a rupt forfacul. Nu l a rupt. Dar nici
plumbul nu l a mai scos. Deci am a
trebuit să rup.
>> Da.
>> Și al treilea a mai făcut o încercare,
dacă cu frâna m a păcălit.
L am lăsat să ia să plece pe Bite
Runner. Am ridicat lanseta
în Am ridicat lanseta în mână. Am lăsat
în continuare pe Bite Runner. S a dus, s
a dus, s a dus și la un moment dat s a
tăiat firul
>> în scoică probabil, că n aveam în ce
>> Deci nici asta n a funcționat.
>> Scoă. Acum hai să facem o mică paranteză
din perspectiva asta pentru că vreau să
dăm și ceva informații urmăritorilor.
Acum na, printre voi este posibil să fie
urmăritori mai specialiști care au
pescuit mai mult în Deta Dunării sau
care nu au pescuit sau n au pescuit pe
praguri. Așa că cei care știți deja
lucrul ăsta, aveți un pic de răbdare.
Mihai, eu am experiența pescuitului pe
sulina, pe praguri și la începuturile
mele când pescuiam pe praguri, lansam și
când recuperam montura se ducea. Și
atunci am început să mă gândesc ce
variante am ca să nu mi se mai taie
montura, că mi se tăia și cu pește. Da.
Și una dintre variante atunci când aveam
drill era exact ce ai spus tu acuma, să
las pe Bite Runner să și ia fir, să se
ducă mult și după care să fac drill ul
și să încerc să l fac mai sus.
>> Dar nu funcționează de fiecare dată.
>> Nu de fiecare dată pentru că dacă firul
este agățat de ceva în prag se taie. Da,
dar ai șanse mai mari decât dacă începi
și tragi tare de el. Sau a doua, dar
asta funcționează atunci când ești
aproape de prag. Noi suntem avem cred că
20 30 de m până la prag. Să faci drill
ul sus cu niște lansete de 3 m, 3,20 m
sau 340 m să faci drillul sus. Asta dacă
și peștele îți permite, dacă este un
pește mic. Eu asta am făcut pe sulina și
am scos în proporție de 80 90% peștii am
reușit să i scot. Da. Deci înțepam lăsam
să și fir și făceam drillul sus. Ok,
asta am vrut să zic despre prag și vreau
să mai completăm un pic de ce pescuim la
prag. Adică ca să înțeleagă logica din
spate de ce peștele stă la prag. Dar zi
mi tu părerea ta de ce vine peștele la
prag și de ce trebuie să pescuim la la
prag?
>> De ce nu pescuim niciodată acuma sau de
>> Nu, putem să discutăm și despre asta,
dar de ce peștele frecventează pragul?
Adică de ce noi pescuim la prag, căutăm
pragurile să pescuim pe ele?
>> Se adună
are de mâncare acolo. Se adună scoică în
pragul ăla.
E pragul ăla e ușor vertical și are și o
scobitură la baza lui.
>> Adică are și o scobitură.
>> Da. Cumva este este așa pragul. Da.
Adică cum a săpat curentul, cum sapă,
sapă și pe dedesubt și nu neapărat doar
curentul, și peștii mai sapă în prag și
atunci fac găurele și așa mai departe.
Și de asta noi căutăm pragurile și
riscăm să pescuim pe praguri, să rupem
monturi pentru că peștele vine și
mănâncă pe praguri. Da. vine și mănâncă
ba la baza pragului, ba pe prag. Acuma
depinde cum este și pragul, ba deasupra
pragului. Da, dar trebuie încercat și de
asta riscăm de multe ori să de riscăm,
pescuim pe prag chiar dacă știm că o să
ne taie să ne taie monturile.
>> Aici noi avem monturile la baza pragului
pentru că nu ai cum să le să le așezi tu
intermediar. N ai N ai cum.
>> Da. Ă, Mihai, explică le, te rog frumos,
cum faci ca promotura să se ajungă la
baza pragului, cum lansezi lansetele.
Deci Mihai a lansat toate lansetele
pentru că eu eram cu funia, cu
ancoratul, cu ce făceam pe aici prin
barcă și Mihai s a pus el și a lansat
toate lansetele. Da, și ca o paranteză,
lansetele trei din dreapta sunt ale
mele, eu pescuiesc cu ele. Lansetele
trei din stânga sunt a lui Mihai. Și
aici mai avem o lansetă de feeder de la
Cristi de la Cristi Borge Real Fishing,
>> pe care Mihai a zis că vrea s o testeze
la maxim. Deci, a pus pe ea o bilă de
32. Da, adică a zis dacă intră o balubă
pe asta vreau să văd ce poate. Este o
lansetă de 24.
Eit o lansetă de la Unichet care este
destul de puternică. Eu am pescuit, am
am încercat, am pescuit și de pe mal cu
ea și ține plumbul de 150, nu 165 de g
foarte bine. Adică lansez foarte ușor cu
el. Este o lansetă foarte puternică,
deși este finuță. Și Mihai a zis că bă
vreau s o
>> dacă în câteva ore n avem trăsătură pe
ea, îi punem o bilă mai de 24, de 22, de
20. Da.
>> Da. Bun. Mihai, povestește ne acum cum
se aruncă din barcă sau de pe mal ca să
prinzi ca să prinzi pragul și cum cum
așezi lansetele, adică cum le așezi așa
frumos să fie toate în linie? În primul
rând, mie nu mi a spus nimeni chestia
asta și nu conștientizam tot timpul.
Prima lansetă pe care o aruncăm este cea
din dreapta. Da. Deci nu începem cu
lanseta din stânga pentru că le vom
agăța pe toate. Da. Că nu știi exact
unde ți pică, dacă reușești să proptești
plumbul. Da. Și lanseta cea mai așezată
în dreapta o aruncăm drept.
>> Da.
>> Da. Deci nu ne ducem cu ea în dreapta, o
aruncăm drept și o să curentul o s o
proptească, o s o aducă, o aduce plumbul
în în prag. Acuma suntem cam la 45° cu
firul față de
>> Da.
>> față de barcă.
și celelalte lansete ușor
ușor în stânga până ajungem cu ultima
lansetă undeva la 45°
față de barcă. Asta în situația în care
pescuim cu șase lansete. Sunt pescari de
cu cabinate care pescuiesc cu opt
lansete, patru cu patru au 10
>> 10 nu e regulamentar.
>> A, ok. Nu se pescuiește cu 10, doar cu
cu patru. Nu se pescuiește cu 10, că s
trei pescari în barcă.
>> Ok. Ok.
>> Au bărcile mai late. Barca asta e un
forward de 550. Are 1,5 lățime și cam
asta e limita maximă, cam trei cu trei.
>> Iar ei au bărci de 2 45 2,5 lățime și și
permit cu să pescuiască cu patru
lansete.
>> Ok. Deci logica, ca s o zicem așa, mai
pe simplu, mergi cu lanseta din dreapta,
o dai pe drept și o lași să ți o ducă
curentul, să ți pringă să ți prindă
pragul. Ideea este că dacă pescuiești cu
barca sau ar trebui să știi cam la ce
distanță este pragul, pentru că tu
trebuie să lansezi mai departe de prag
și curentul îți aduce montura și s o
bagă în prag. Deci, ai lăsat prima
montură, ai lansat prima lansetă, ți a
băgat o în prag, după care o lansezi pe
a doua și tu îți aduci aminte unde ai
lansat, că ai lăsat ai lansat drept, te
duci cu ea un pic în stânga și la fel le
faci pe toate. Zi corect, Mihai? Da.
>> Și la fel le faci pe toate. Că normal
ele ar trebui să cadă toate în evantai.
Da. Adică pentru că curentul este
același, plumbul este acela și ar trebui
să scadă toate una lângă alta. Ok. Deci
cam asta este. Lansat.
>> Mai avem o completare după ce lansăm mai
departe de prag, mai departe cu 6 10 m,
mai departe de prag, lăsăm plumbul
>> să cadă pe
pe fund, dar nu lăsăm. Deci întotdeauna
la lansăm și eu țin mâna pe tambur
cumva. Țin mâna pe tambur, dar foarte
ușor să nu ca să simți firul. Să nu ia
mult simți firul să nu ia mult, dar nici
să nu l blochez.
Apoi, după ce am simțit că a atins
că a atins fundul,
îi dau pick upul și nu trag tare, deci
nu mulinez ușor de tot și curentul aduce
plumbul. Nu, nu încerc eu să blochez
plumbul în prag în situația în care avem
prag vertical. În restul situațiilor mai
>> mai forțez și poți să l blochezi mai
repede decât normal decât l ar bloca
curentul.
>> Ok. Bun. Mihai. Acum vreau să vorbim un
pic de strategie. Ce folosim, cum
folosim, să povestești un pic și de
fluocarbon.
Dar prima dată hai să vorbim despre
nădire. Cum am făcut noi nădirea și de
ce este importantă nădirea și cum o
facem pe parcursul zilei. Da, hai să
începem de la început. Deci am ajuns pe
locul de pescuit. Ăă,
ne am uitat cu sonarul din nou să vedem
unde este pragul, deși ăă Mihai știa. Ă
după care am început să l înădim în
amonte cu o palețică din fața bărcii. În
evantai.
Am început să nădim din fața bărcii. Cam
câte kilograme crezi că am dat, Mihai?
Nu, nu mi dau seama.
>> Când? De dimineață.
>> De dimineață, da.
>> 3 4 kg.
>> 3 4 kg. Da. În evantai. Cu
barca mers pe înainte. Mihai ținea,
>> dar nu ne am dus foarte,
>> dar nu foarte mult. Foarte în amonte, nu
știu cât, 20 de m cam așa,
>> în funcție și de curent.
>> Acum în funcție de cât de puternic este
curentul, de cât de mari sunt bilele, de
cât de grele sunt bilele. Da,
>> pe cota asta cu curentul nu e atât de
>> Da, nu este atât de puternic. Și am am
nădit, deci am nădit, am început
nădirea. Iar la fiecare jumătate de oră,
o oră A, apropo, am nădit cu bile
semisolubile.
>> Da.
>> Aici mai este o chestie. Mihai are o
schemă pe care și eu o folosesc. Când
ajunge pe locul de pescuită
nădește cu bile solubile sau semiolubile
pentru că vrea să se activeze repede pe
substrat. După care nădește cu bile
tari. Da, cu bile. Nădește și cu bile
fish meal. Nădește și cu bile cu bile
Burfood. Ok. Iar noi acum la jumătate de
oră, o oră dăm cu praștia câteva bile pe
zona unde noi pescuim. Da. Câteva bine.
Cam câte bile dă, Mihai, în într o într
o sesiune de renădit?
>> Depinde cât cât suntem cât de dispuși
suntem să nădim des. Eu aș nădi din
jumate jumate de oră, dar de multe ori
te iei cu altele prin barcă. Eu știu 30
40 de boiless uri o dată la o oră, să
zicem.
>> Hm. Hm. Ok. Perfect.
>> Date ușor în stânga bărcii.
>> Exact. Exact. Ca să întreținem să
întreținem vadul. Aici mai fac o mică
paranteză ca să vă zic ce s
>> mai mai multe solubile și sau și
semiolubile decât tari.
>> Da,
>> elele tari cam 30% și restul solubile,
semisolubile.
>> Noi acum vorbim de
>> doar nu doar fish meal.
>> Da. Nu doar fish și nu vă bazați doar pe
fishmeal, că puteți să veniți cu fish
meal și să vă uitați lung la lansete
patru zile.
>> Nu e clar. Deci când pleci în Delta
Domnului e o regulă. Fish Meal și
Burfood. Deci trebuie să ai la tine și
Fis Meal și Burfood. Și Mihai acuma hai
să mai dăm și din casă. Mihai
face nădirea cu bile de diferite
dimensiuni și bilele care sunt cele mai
urâte din punct de vedere comercial,
adică și dacă sunt un pic pătrățoase, un
pic dumble, alea îi plac cel mai mult.
De ce? pentru că el nu vrea să
trezească suspiciuni peștelui.
>> Mie îmi place să Noi la fabrică avem și
rebooturi.
>> Da. Da. Și eu îi spun lui Gabi,
întotdeauna mie dă mi cele mai diformeil
uri. Când se fac când se fac bilele. Mai
există și rebooturi care nu se pot vinde
ca și produse finite pentru că nu arată
na conform standardelor și atunci noi le
păstrăm și nădim cu ele pentru că s
foarte bune. Deci noi nădim cu bile de
24, cu bile de 20 și cu spărturi, dacă
se sparg. Deci nu este o problemă asta
pentru că vrem ca peștele să nu să nu
creadă
că ceva este în neregulă pe substrat.
Ok.
>> Și să nu și regleze să să nu reușească
să și regleze absorbția.
>> Absorție. Exact.
>> Ideal ar fi să avem și 16 și 30
solubile.
>> Da, ideal. Ideal. Dar în principiu în
principiu așa facem.
Acum noi pescuim la pește mari. Da. La
pește mare pescuim cu momitoare. Cu
momitoare, cu Eu s obișnuit să pescuiesc
cu momitoare pentru că mie îmi place
mult activitatea. Mie îmi place să
pescuiesc mult la ciortan. Dar acum
pescuim cu plumbi in line, cu bilet de
24, de 20 și chiar de 30. Mihai, acum te
rog frumos să mi povestești despre
fluocarbon. Eu n am folosit până acum
fluurocarbonul pe deltă.
Eu sunt adeptul firului textil, dar
Mihai mi a tot spus cu fluurocarbonul.
Mihai, spune mi logica. Eu o știu pentru
că mi ai povestit o, dar spune mi logica
pentru cameră și de ce crezi tu că
fluurocarbonul în anumite situații poate
să fie mai bun decât decât textilul?
>> Eu pescuiesc cu toate cele trei tipuri
de fire, cu fir textil normal, cu fir
textil cămășuit și cu fluorocarbon. Deci
sunt pregătit pentru toate variantele. Ă
firul cămășuit și fluorocarbonul
se pretează mai bine, din punctul meu de
vedere, atunci când pescuiești din mai
din mal în 90° față de apă și ai mai
multe mai puține șanse să
nu se încurcă în aruncare montura. Da.
Și pe textilul normal poți să i pui
un antitangle. Eu am început ieri
partida cu textil normal, cu antiangle.
Nu am, într adevăr, n am avut, n am scos
decât una sau două monturi încurcate,
>> dar nici prezentări n am avut. Până n am
schimbat toate monturile pe
fluorocarbon,
nu am avut trăsături.
>> Hm.
>> Explică logica. explică logica aici ca
să înțeleagă mai bine.
>> Fluorocarbonul se se spune că nu este
nu e văzut în apă de de pești. E
insesizabil.
>> Hhm.
>> Ăsta este unul dintre motive. Iar al
doilea motiv ar putea fi faptul că este
rigid. În momentul în când absoarbe, el
nu mai poate să l scuipe pentru că este
rigid și nu mai are cum. În schimb, da
>> poate să l scem mult mai ușor. Oricum,
noi astăzi facem un test. Lansetele
mele, cele trei pe partea dreaptă sunt
pe fir textil. Au rămas rig pe fir
textil și Mihai pe cele din pe cele trei
din partea stângă are rig de fluocarbon.
Și astăzi o să vedem așa un pic pe
frecvența trăsăturilor dacă
aduce mai multe rezultate fluocarbonul.
Cred că una e pe cămășuit pentru că nu
am mai nu mai am monturi. Am am pierdut
ieri șase 7te opt monturi aice sau mai
bine cred.
>> Cred că vreo 10.
>> Da, e un pic mai dificil pescuitul pe
prag, dar aduce și rezultate. M faptul
că de fapt hai să povestim un pic ce se
întâmplă în Delta Dunării acum, de ce nu
se prinde pește și de ce se prinde mult
mai rar.
Zi tu, Mihai, pentru că haideți să vă
zic un pic de Mihai. Ce face Mihai?
Mihai este un pescar de Delta Dunării
care are o experiență foarte mare și el
la bază este inginer. Ce face un
inginer? Își notează toate informațiile.
Așa că Mihai are un tabel XL în care
>> e făcut împreună cu cu Cosmin Panait.
Deci am adunat
>> informații de la amândoi.
Eu am făcut un tabel mai simplu. Și
Cosmin l a dus la alt nivel
>> H
>> cu grafice, cu o nebunie. Exact.
>> O nebunie de tabel. Poate
>> pentru noi ăștia care nu suntem ingineri
sunt SF uri, dar pentru ei este foarte
interesant. și din
din istoricul partidelor desfășurate în
ani de zile
ă unde am notat întotdeauna
cota ă temperatura
apei, presiune atmosferică
>> și punând toate datele astea cap la cap
am ajuns la concluzia
că în anumite perioade
pescuitul a mers mai bine
>> pe anumită cotă, pe anumită presiune și
așa mai departe.
>> Exact. Încă n o să vă Încă n o să vă
spunem care sunt condițiile
>> optime. O să mai facem să facem mai
multe clipuri în care Mihai a promis din
suflet că o să
>> Te rog să nu mă Deja Deja am dat prea
multe informații.
>> Bine, bine, bine. Lasă mă, lasă mai lasă
mă să mai zic ceva. Mihai a promis că o
să ne dea mai multe informații pe
parcurs în timp ce o să facem mai multe
clipuri. Dar vă zic așa ca să povestim
ce se întâmplă în perioada asta în Delta
Dunării, pentru că vreau ca pescarii să
înțeleagă un lucru, că în Delta Dunării
nu se prinde pește non stop.
Da. Și aș vrea să înțeleagă cu cât au
mai multe informații,
cu atât au șanse să prindă pește în
Delta Dunării. Și vreau să mi povestești
ce s a întâmplat în partida asta pentru
că nu am avut, să zicem, cea mai bună
frecvență în pește mare, să prindem
pește mare. Ok. S au prins câțiva
ciortani, dar nu este ce trebuie. Știi
cum cum spunem noi pescarii, băi, nu e
ce trebuie. Da, de asta am și schimbat
multe locuri și ne am plimbat mult. Zi
ne, Mihai. Cotă.
>> Păi am avut fluctuații de
condiții atmosferice, presiune
atmosferică
în creștere,
>> hm
>> și cotă în scădere.
>> Deci în principal
schimbările
de presiune, cotă, temperatură nu nu i
plac.
>> Exact. Pescuitul a funcționat foarte,
foarte bine săptămâna trecută,
miercuri, joi, vineri, când presiunea
atmosferică a fost stabilă
>> și cota într o ușoară scădere,
>> ușoară, deci nu bruscă. Acum na, mergem
din nou pe comportamentul crapului. Ce
face crapul? Sâmbătă, vineri spre
sâmbătă
dimineață s a s a tăiat în toată deci în
toată delta
>> când înainte de furtună
>> Da, da,
>> înainte de furtună s a mai prins un pic,
deci se mai prinde până să înceapă
furtuna și după aia după aia se cam
taie.
>> Nu ne plângem. Am prins un pește de 13
kg. Am prins ciortani, am mâncat, na, am
făcut și noi un pește la tigaie și am
mâncat aseară
>> și am luat ieri, voi ați luat doi de
vreo 5 kg pe mal, eu am luat de șase, de
>> au mai fost și alea trei trăsături.
Bineînțeles că ăia, cei scăpați au fost
cei mai mari. Da, da, da, da, da. Normal
că ați știți cum e. Acuma, ca să
înțelegeți de ce zic că eu în clipurile
mele zic că nu mi s a întâmplat să merg
în Delta Dunării și să plec fără să
prind pește
pentru că noi îl căutăm. Deci noi avem
foarte multe informații. Eu vorbesc mult
cu Mihai la telefon în momentul în care
eu sunt singur sau el pleacă singur sau
cu alți prieteni și ne sfătuim unde ești
sunt acolo, ce putem să facem Nu merge
finețe. Adică adunăm foarte multe
informații și le punem cap la cap ca să
creăm o strategie pentru fiecare partidă
pentru că nicio partidă nu seamănă ca
alta. M am sunat Mihai Viner și zice:
„Gabriel, hai să mergem în deltă că
rupem peștele." Hai că așa ai zis.
>> Așa am zis. Da,
>> așa ai zis, nu? Ok. Și eu la fel. cotă
aia aia aia presiune. Zic mi hai să
mergem. Eram cu bagajele la ușă, hai să
mergem și bineînțeles că am ajuns și nu
a fost așa. Da. Deci asta se poate
întâmp duminică duminică seară când eram
la
>> când când eram la festival la Nostalgia,
ți am dat mesaj, bă, putem să mai dacă
dacă mai ai ceva de rezolvat pe acasă
putem s o mai amânăm un pic și care mai
gata că am zis că mergem, mergem. A a
dat un pic înapoi, Mihai, pentru că a
văzut că se schimbă se schimbă
condițiile și
>> eram dispus să amânăm până cam să venim
astăzi
>> până joi pentru că am observat că joi
>> presiunea atmosferică se va stabiliza
pentru o perioadă, iar apoi va scădea
ușor.
>> Hm. Hm.
>> Deci m a m a debusolat furtuna aia de
sâmbătă, duminică. E era clar că l dă
peste cap.
>> Da, da, da, da. E asta este o ăsta este
pescuitul în Delta Dunării. Da, de asta
ne place pescuitul în Delta Dunării,
pentru că nu știm când plecăm de acasă
nu știm. Deși noi ne facem planuri de
acasă și știm de acasă, ne pregătim cu
ce avem nevoie, dar ajungem pe apă și nu
știm ce se va întâmpla.
Adică faptul că am
>> 8 la 32 la bil de 32
este
>> Este Mihai
>> a fost ceva dar cred că i propit în
prag.
>> Lasă, dă i fir. Deci la bilă de 32 la
lanseta de feeder de la real fishing, ca
să înțelegeți, la bilă de 32. Da,
>> dar n am ce să i fac decât Nu, lasă l,
lasă l. Îl las că nu n am ce să i fac.
>> Dar se simte ceva acolo. Păi
>> se simte. Dar
>> lasă l că iese singur.
Mamă, dizabilă de 32. Vă dați seama? Da,
>> dar nu era foarte mare.
>> Sigur nu era foarte mare nu era foarte
Nu, nu era foarte mare.
>> Abila te referi sau ce?
>> Da. Nu, peștele.
>> Peștele.
>> Deci un crap de de 4 5 kg. O ia fără
probleme în perioada asta.
>> Da, ce ziceam?
>> Mamă, iar trece. Cine trece? C C C ăsta?
A, Harry.
>> A, uite, Hari e prinde pește. Este cu
noi la pescuit sunt trei prieteni cu
noi. Este Cosmin și este și Harry cu
noi.
>> Vrei să l filmezi sau?
>> Și Cosmin nu, că n ajunge până acolo. Și
Harry deja are și el un drill. Deci
vedeți ce se întâmplă în momentul în
care începe să tragă la cineva parcă
începe pe toat a tras aici și Harry and
Drill. Harry and drill.
Îs curios. A l a scăpat Harry.
>> Scăpat.
>> Stai pescuitul. N avem ce face.
Mai trece și un vapor acuma mare care o
să facă multe
O să facă niște valuri mari.
>> Stai că vreau să l întreb pe Harry cum
era. Cum era? Intră mare.
>> Cum era Hari?
Era baban.
Hari a făcut așa.
>> Da,
>> cred că trebuie să la lanseta aia. Laeta
e așa pusă într o parte și trebuie cred
că să i dai drumul la frână mai bine. Să
nu să nu se n o pierdem.
>> Să nu se supere Cristi pe noi.
>> Dar nu, nu, că trebuie să O să ia firul.
Da, aia nu o să încerc să n am N am ce
să fac.
>> Hai, încearcă să scoți.
E în prag. Nu.
>> Ce?
Acuma se vede.
>> Da. S a rupt.
>> S a rupt, nu?
>> Da.
>> Ăsta este pescuitul pe prag.
Dar și când se aliniază toate astrele,
când peștele ia montura și pleacă cu ea
în larg și scoate firul din prag și
toate cele și vine pe deasupra, atunci
avem capturi frumoase.
Deci, Mihai 10 peștele, nu?
>> Da.
>> Ieri a fost 32 pentru pește, nu?
>> Da. Da.
>> 32 pentru pește. Ne vedem astăzi dacă ne
luăm răvanșa.
La
>> Am plecat cu Am pornit cu stângul.
Nuă, e cu stângul, mă. E cu dreptul, că
avem trăsătură deja de 15 minute de când
le am aruncat, nu? 15 20 de minute.
>> Deci e cu dreptul dacă avem trăsătură.
Tu știi că eu de multe ori zic, bă, dă
mi o trăsătură. Atât. O trăsătură vreau
să văd. Chiar dacă se rupe, nu i
problemă, dar vreau să văd o trăsătură.
>> Încă o să i punem o montură mai normală
pentru o
ă Vă rog să ne scuzați un pic cadrul.
Avem nevoie de bin mini pentru că este
cald afară și avem nevoie de umbră
și na, nu este un cadru tocmai perfect.
O să încerc să filmez și cu telefonul
dacă avem ceva drilluri ca să vă arătăm
și peștele în drill. Dar cam atât, cam
atât se poate.
Mihai, unde rămăsesem cu discuția? Că
simt că n am terminat o, dar nu mai știu
ce ziceam. M de Vorbeam de condițiile
atmosferice.
>> Vorbeam de condițiile atmosferice. Da,
nu mai știu exact. Ideea este în felul
următor. Ce vreau eu să vă transmit este
faptul că nu vom prinde pește de fiecare
dată când plecăm în Delta Dunării, cum
se întâmplă și pe bălțile suprapopulate.
Te duci pe te duci la pescuit și
deși știi că balta are foarte mult pește
și nu prinzi pește. Și chiar îmi
povestea Roland, inginerul piscicol, de
un prieten de al lui care avea o baltă
cu 3 pear sau ceva de genul ăsta, 2, 3,
pe hectar, ceea ce este foarte mult. Și
patronul bălții a participat la un
concurs acolo, a picat pe mijlocul
bălții și n a prins niciun pește. Deci
voi vă dați seama patronul, el știa cât
pește avea în baltă și el n a prins
niciun pește. Da. Așa că astea s
condițiile la pescuit pe parcurs.
Furcuță. Furfecuță sau nu? Ok.
>> Vezi că este a
>> Ok,
>> pe parcurs noi o să vă mai povestim un
pic despre pescuit, o să vă dăm mai
multe informații despre pescuit în așa
fel încât să ajungeți ca aproape de
fiecare dată să aveți rezultate. Dar
probabil nu în clipul acesta. Trebuie să
l mai convingem un pic pe Mihai. Trebuie
să vadă din partea voastră niște
comentarii acolo, să l încurajăm un pic
să ne dea din casă pentru că este un
pescar foarte bun. Cred că rămăsesem la
tabelul acela.
este un pescar foarte bun care a studiat
știința din spate a pescuitului, care nu
a pus cel mai mare preț pe
nade și momeli.
>> Iar pește.
>> Nu știu ce ce spune Harry. Nu știu,
>> nu te am înțeles.
>> Dacă mai trebuie mumit
>> ă din din oră în oră mai dă i câteva
bile.
care s a gândit mai mult la logica din
spate a lucrurilor decât în nade și
momeli și de ce face el, cred eu de ce
face el lucrul ăsta, dar vă spun de ce
fac eu lucrul ăsta, de ce încerc să caut
logica din spate a lucrurilor. Pentru
faptul că vreau să repet, vreau să
repet. Vreau să știu de ce am prins
pește, vreau să știu de ce n am prins
pește, vreau să știu ce am greșit,
pentru că data viitoare să pot să repet
experiența. Dacă nu știu lucrurile
astea, nu pot să repet. Și Mihai, cred
că și la tine este valabil treaba asta.
>> Da.
>> Ok.
Cam atât. Așa. V am făcut o mică
povestioară despre ce s a întâmplat în
aceste trei zile. Mai avem încă două
zile de pescuit, aproape trei. Sâmbătă o
să plecăm din deltă. Sâmbătă nu știu,
după prânz când o să vrea Mihai.
Și până atunci pescuim. Sper eu să
reușesc să filmez lucrurile importante.
Este un pic dificil pentru noi să filmăm
pentru că nu suntem
videourați.
>> Îi bag îi bag o căpșunică de 20.
>> Bagă.
>> A și de cârlig sau doar din direct din
sac?
>> Da, îți dau și de cârlig. Stai un pic.
>> Ok. Mai ca să fie mai solubilă un pic.
>> Da, da, da, da. Îți dau, îți dau.
Iar mi am uitat ideea. Ce voiam să zic?
A, da.
Nu suntem videografi și ne este destul
de greu să poziționăm camera, să ne
aducem mereu aminte, să dăm drumul la
ea, să punem lavarierele, că oricum o să
vedeți câteva filmări fără la variere și
suntem pe microfonul de la GoPro, care
nu se aude foarte bine. Așa că vă rog să
ne scuzați toate lucrurile acestea
tehnice și să vă uitați dincolo de
dincolo de camere și să vedeți
informațiile pe care le primiți. Ok?
Stați că nu i până la final. V am vorbit
despre nădire și acum vreau să vă arăt
cu ce nădim noi și cu ce pescuim la
cârlic.
Pescuim cu produsele din gama GDA
Fishing, cu bilele de nădit de la sacii
de 5 kg și cu bila de cârlig din borcan.
Ă iar
fish ul pe care î avem la noi este
rețeta lui Mihai. Este rețeta pe care
Mihai o testează de 10 ani de zile Mihai
>> în Delta Dunării și a avut niște capturi
>> impresionante cu cu ele. Poate, Mihai,
îmi trimiți câteva poze să le pun așa pe
ecran, pac pac pac, ca să le vadă, să le
vadă
urmăritorii noștri. Bilele
nu sunt ambalate momentan. Ele arată
Eleată cam așa. Aici sunt amestecate și
de 20 și de 24.
Așa va arata va arăta eticheta. Asta
este o etichetă scoasă,
improvizată și pusă pe capac. Na, a vrut
Mihai să să vadă cum arată.
Și
sunt bile tari. Deci sunt bile tari,
sunt bile fierte. Iar bilele
semisolubile
din gama GDA Fishing sunt bile nefierte,
iar acestea rezistă în curent. Acuma,
depinde de Depinde foarte mult de
curent, depinde dacă ai pește mic pe vad
sau nu ai pește mic. Depinde de mai
mulți factori. La fel și bila, de
temperatura apei. La fel și bila și bila
fiartă de la Mihai. Dacă ai mai mult
pește pe vaz și este cald afară, se
topește mai repede. Dar în condiții
generale bila din sac semisolubilă
îți stă în medie între o oră jumate,
două ore jumătate, se duce și până la 3
ore. Ok. Iar bila lui Mihai te ține
toată noaptea. Acuma la fel, în funcție
de
pește, în funcție de curent, în funcție
de temperatura apei. Noi ce am pescuit
cu ea cel puțin bila de 24. Aseară am
băgat trei bilete 24 pe trei lansete,
pentru că doar atâte am avut la apă
aseară și dimineață le am scos. Erau
frumos activate, arătau foarte bine. De
fapt, chiar le am aruncat pe alea. Le am
aruncat tot pe alea. Da. Mihai cu bilele
astea aprins peștii pe care o să i
vedeți pe ecran sau pe care deja i ați
văzut. Nu știu cum o să pun pozele.
Nădim cu toate, deci și fish Meal și
Burood. La Burood avem variantă de
căpșună și de sicret aroma. Iar fish
Meal ul este într o singură variantă pe
care Mihai a făcut o până acum. Și fish
ul o să fie pe piață, dar fish meal ul
Hai, Mihai, să vorbim un pic de Fishmal.
>> Hai, hai, te rog eu. Ideea este în felul
următor. Depinde ce căutați în Delta
Dunării. Dacă activitate, mergem pe
Burood, mergem pe solubilitate. Da, dacă
activitatea, adică dacă vreți în Delta
Dunării să prindeți pește mult și mic,
mergeți pe solubilitate. Zic bine,
Mihai? Da, da,
>> așa. Burnfood și solubilitate.
La cârlig eu am bile și mai solubile
decât cele din sac pentru că se
activează mai repede, iar solubilitatea
prinde pește. Cu cât bila se activează
mai repede, cu atât ai șanse să prinzi
mai repede pește. Dacă v ați uitat la
clipurile pe care le am făcut eu alte
clipuri în Delta Dunării, eu am pescuit
pe canale am pescuit cu solubile. Da. Și
cire cireașa de pe tort de la borcane
este
este o bilă sau o peletă super solubilă.
se activează foarte repede ca să ți
aducă repede trăsătura. În schimb, când
vorbim de pește mare, vorbim de așteptat
pe trăsătură și vorbim de o bilă care să
stea la cârlig și vorbim de o bilă fish
meal pentru că peștele mare
consumă mai multă proteină decât peștele
mic. Și avem o trăsătură.
Hai să vedem dacă o iau ca lumea. Așa.
Lasă l să se ducă.
>> Lasă las se ducă dacă vrei. Las.
>> Nu știu. Nici nu știu ce să ți să ți
spun. Stai să iau și telefonul.
Ați văzut, dragi pescari, am avut o
trăsătură. L am lăsat să ia fir. L am
lăsat să ia fir, dar tot în prag a fost
și n am avut ce face. A trebuit să
tragem de el. Până la urmă s a rupt. Îl
așteptăm pe următorul.
>> Filmez.
>> Hai.
>> A trecut de prag.
>> Ok. Dar nu e mare.
>> Stai puțin,
am dat drumul la filmare. Stai să iau
lanseta asta de aicea.
Stai să dau de aice. Ridică un pic
piciorul. Gata. Să ți fac loc.
>> Deci, dragi pescari,
a venit un pește. Acum al doilea pește.
Nu e mare.
Deci am avut o trăsătură s a rupt în
prag. Și pe ăsta am reușit să l scot din
prag.
Minciogul.
Hopa! Așa!
Așa. Lasă că l iau eu. Tu du te în
spate.
>> Haide, mă, tu te acolo.
Așa.
>> Lanseta.
>> Ia uite bilele.
>> Lanseta poți s o
>> Asta vreau.
>> Suport. Țin eu un pic așa.
>> Deci și uită te. Ia filmează aici, te
rog frumos, să vadă cum Să se vadă cum a
mâncat bilele. Uitați ce a scos.
>> Deci sunt Deci nu e fish meal ul. Da, e
>> Deci nu e fish meul.
>> Am Amfoodul îl dat de dimineață. Eu eu
am dat peste.
>> Nu mi place cum stă suportul ăsta. Deci,
dragi pescari, dacă vă uitați aici acum
a început să elimine ce are în intestin
și se vede clar fishm ul. Uite și bucata
mare. Vezi?
>> Nu e Nu. Deci nu i fish me.
>> Scuze. Buroodul. Bur foodul. Da. Deci
>> e secret aroma. Secreta ăla roș nu e
căpșunica. E secreta aroma. Da,
>> da dimineață nu i am
>> Cu asta am nădit. Da.
>> Și cu căpșunică?
>> Nu, n am dat căpșun.
>> Nu. Căpșunica am aruncat doar eu cu
praștia.
>> Dă mi o. Da. Dă mi o cârpă. Mai ai pe
aici?
>> Stai puțin. Așa. Să l ții un pic totuși
ca să revină.
>> Da. Da.
>> Colegul nostru pescar din partea dreaptă
a scos acum un pește la 7 kg. Cred că
are 7 kg.
>> O să l O să l cântărească și o să vă
spun.
>> Nu e e Nu i așa mare.
>> Cred că are șapte. O opt.
>> Cam aici.
>> Cred că șapte.
>> Iar noi
>> Iar noi ruptură
>> din trăsătură.
>> Din trăsătură direct. Da. Deci fir de
0,40 ăsta nu.
>> Da. Tren din US
direct din trăsătură. Da. Bine, pescuim
pe prag. Na, nu zicem neapărat că a fost
ăla de 50 de kg, ci efectiv că ne a rupt
din trăsătură.
>> Pescarii care urmăresc peștele mare din
Delta Dunării de obicei pescuiesc cu
fire de 0,45 050. Da,
>> eu mă încăpățânez în continuare să dau
cu 0 ca să dau o șansă și peștelui
>> și eu am 0,13.
>> Cosmin tocmai ce mi a spus că și peștele
lui a eliminat bilă galbenă.
>> Secret aroma de secret aroma
>> de Bine, cu asta noi secret aroma de 20
de mm.
La fel ca peștele de dinainte. Deci se
hrănește, e pe patul de nadă și așteptăm
să intre și la noi unul mare. Bine, să
putem să l scoatem că e a intrat.
>> Deci cât e? 3 1 pentru pește.
Patru.
>> 3 Da. 4 1 pentru. Deci am scăpat patru
și am reușit să scoatem unul de 4 kg la
poză.
>> Ia vedeți, băieți, este ora 12:00.
>> Mulțumim mult, domnul Răsoiu.
>> Prietenul nostru ne a făcută și a adus
aici întins.
>> Ceva să încingem la tigaie.
Luăm și noi masa și să mai prindem
câțiva pești, nu? Sigur.
Și haideți să vă arăt ce am găsit aici,
unde ne vom instala tabăra.
Niște oase
de porc mistreț.
[Muzică]
Dragi pescari, am mâncat.
Prietenul nostru Cosmin ne a făcut o
super surpriză. A adus niște pastramă de
plășcoi și cu cârnați de plășcoi și am
făcut așa pe mal o o ciobănească
autentică.
Am mâncat, ne a luat un pic somnul.
Mihai chiar voia să se întindă un pic să
doarmă.
Și am avut un run, am avut un ciortan la
3 kg,
același stil. A
na, a tras, a intrat un pic pe ran, după
care l am ridicat. Între timp am
schimbat lansetele, am pus pe plumbier
și surpriza mea a fost să văd că după ce
am descățat peștele, să văd că plumbul
dispăruse. Deci asta înseamnă că
strategia noastră funcționează cu
plumbul pierdut. Plung plumbul a rămas
în prag. Probabil că dacă nu puneam plum
pierdut, rămânea plumul inline în prag
și trebuia să rupăm să rupem montura.
Ce am mai făcut eu a fost să îmi pun un
fir
conic care pleacă de la 018 până la
0,57,
dar în 15 m, adică de la
de la 1 m unde are unde are 01 se duce
până la 15 m, crește în grosime până la
0,57,
dar l am tăiat undeva pe la jumătate. Ai
trăsăturat? Nu, nu, nu vreau să le
>> L am tăiat undeva la jumătate și
probabil că am plecat pe la de la un 028
>> și l am pus ca înaintaș.
Cam astea s modificările pe care le am
făcut. Pește s a prins. Harry, care este
cu noi și este ultimul din rândul de
bărci a scos un ciortan la 5 kg. De
fapt, ciortan nu prea mai e ciortan la 5
kg. Și acuma este iar în drill și văd că
se chinuie ceva și zice că este un pește
mare. Așteptăm să vedem. Cât de mare
este? Ient acolo
>> și
cam atât. L ai luat Hari?
Cât e?
Cât?
>> 10.
Ridică l un pic la cameră să l vedem.
Bravo lui. Deci, dragilor, avem și pește
mare pe B.
De deja nu.
>> Deci ia uite, ia uite
>> o.
>> Bine, Harry.
[Muzică]
Când adem e ok să ai mai sus ca să ai
cursă. cazul în care pleacă. Știi
>> e
ține de
>> vin să te ajut?
>> Gata.
>> Cât are,
>> mă? Carul,
>> du te, mă, de aici! Carul!
>> Bine, mă, Cosmin!
>> Bă, dacă nu intră
>> ia ridică l un pic că suntem pe filmare.
>> Oho!
>> Bravo!
>> 9500,
>> dragi pescari, eliberare.
Felicitări, Cosmin!
Bravo!
>> Gata,
>> bravo, Cosmin! Felicitări!
[Muzică]
Ia uitați, dragi pescari, un incendiu în
toată regula în fața noastră.
Deci
le am avut pe toate în partida asta.
Incendiu, caniculă,
mutări, pești apatici.
Ce să mai?
>> Am avut și pește frumos și pești
frumoși.
>> Am prins peștele.
>> Rateuri multe de tot,
atât noi cât și colegii noștri Hari și
cu Cosmin.
Da,
Mihai, ăsta se cam întățește.
Noi avem tabăra mai sus un pic.
Mă rog, tabăra. Încă n am pus tabăra.
Sunt doar bagajele pentru că le am mutat
le am mutat astăzi
și sperăm să
putem să campăm aici dacă nu trebuie să
plecăm.
>> Unde rămăsesem?
>> Rămăsesem. Hai să facem așa. Harry,
acum în ultima în săptămâna asta ai
prescris cu bilele rețeta făcută de
Mihai.
>> Da.
>> Da. Cum ți s a părut?
Adică am avut așa încredere în în
boilis, adică din prima zi de când am
pus
am prins,
am avut rupturi,
mi a intrat în ancoră, mi a intrat, mi a
mâncat boilul de asupra cârligului. Păi
mai multă reclamă nu trebuie să pui la
în boilist la
>> Dar ai spus o chestie
Am avut din prima încredere.
>> Da. Deci poți să mirosul ăla mirosul ăla
m o m o mi o
>> Dar știi care
cu orice boiles ai pescui. Nu, nu, nu
neapărat cu ăsta, cu orice și cu
Decathlon și cu orice boiles. Din
punctul meu de vedere, cel mai important
e să ai încredere în
>> să ai înus încredere în produs. Da.
>> Adică când începi că în barcă ai 10
produse care să l pun, știi? Și atunce
ai stricat ziua de pescuit. Ai stricat
ziua de pescu te ai uitat că să dau cu
ăla cu ăla cu ăla. Nu, asta trebuie
trage la ăsta. Asta trebuie elinată.
Trebuie eliminat. Te ții la ăsta.
>> Corect.
>> Am stricat, să zicem, o zi. N au fost
bune.
>> Așa e. le dai deoparte, iei a doua.
>> Și din cauza asta o partidă de pescuit,
adică extrem cum am făcut o noi,
trebuie o săptămână.
>> Da, da. N ai cum. N ai cum. Mai puțin de
o săptămână. N ai cum.
>> Da, că trebuie să te gândești am pierdut
câteva zile.
>> Da.
>> De pescuit. Dar contează contează Nu
contează că n am prins pește. Aia i
ceva. Dar satisfacția că bila lucrează
peste tot. Aia da.
>> Ai prins pe obris?
>> Da.
>> Ai prins ă sus? Da.
>> Ai prins și aici? Da.
>> Peste tot. Unde a fost pește? Prins
toată lumea.
>> Unde a fost pește? S a prins pește.
>> Păi ce vrei?
>> Unde?
>> Încă o chestie interesantă. Mi s a părut
foarte foarte interesant. Noi la un
moment dat eram la depărtare,
nu știu, 150 de m. 200 de m uni față de
alții.
>> Da.
>> Când a când a tras atunce tu erai în
drill,
a urmat imediat când erai trăsătură
Harry Drill și la noi
ruptură din trăsătură. Adică când a
început să mănânce
>> Da. când să vină cârdul,
>> când vine ora lui și cârdul începe la la
toată lumea.
Corect.
Tu mai filmezi? Ce faci acolo? Mai
>> Da, dar am schimbat un pic poziția ca să
ne vedem mai bine, că mi se pare că
sunt.
>> Voiam cu ocazia asta să i salutăm.
>> Dar ce ce ți au căzut acolo?
>> Nu, nu, nu e. Să i salutăm și pe cei
care cu care ne am ne am auzit în
săptămâna asta, cu Marius Țigănuș care e
la Nufăru și ne a tot trimis poze. S a
prins pe Sfântul Gheorghe s a și s a
prins destul de bine și nu numai Marius
s a prins, s au prins și și alții pe
Sfântu Gheorghe. Erfan, dacă nu mă
înșel, cu care ne am întâlnit la Obrize,
a plecat la o zi după noi. Deci au
plecat de pe obrize și s au mutat pe
Sfântul Gheorghe și azi au avut o
partidă deosebită.
>> Au avut un dublu drill cu 10 plus sau
ceva de genul ăsta. Vreau să l salutăm
și pe pe Costel Velicu cu care ne am
întâlnit în
zona Ostrov,
pe Marian Mincu. Ne am întâlnit cu el și
cu Cipi pe pe obrize și cireașa de pe
tort. Când am ajuns la Chilia de aicea
luni așa, n aveau benzină.
Sile,
>> sile.
>> Sile era
>> era cu morcovul. Noi mai aveam aveam
benzină de de rezervă, mai aveam vreo 40
de l noi și ne am continuat ne am
continuat drumul
și cam asta a fost.
>> Vasile nu prea au pescuit că mai mult au
dormit.
>> Ține dacă te uiți la clip, uite ce i Ce
Harry.
>> E e e la a pescuit după. A scos și el un
13. Ce are acolo în 14? A scos frumos. A
scos dește
>> Sile. A stat cu noi trei zile, după care
a plecat cu niște prieteni mai sus de
Tulcea și ne a trimis astăzi o poză, de
fapt, ne a sunat pe cameră și ne a
arătat un pește frumos de 13.
>> Da, da, da, da, da,
>> da,
>> da. S a văzut cine era cu ghionul? Noi
>> cred că eu am fost.
>> Nu cred.
>> Nu, nu. Auzi, nu, nu, nu. Eu nu cred.
>> Aoleu! Da,
>> noi zicem, noi zicem despre această
partidă că n am prins pește, dar de fapt
noi am prins pește.
Noi am prins ciortan de 3 4 5 kg am
prins, dar noi am stat doar pe pește
mare. Doar pe pește
>> mare. Cosmin a luat de șapte. Nu zic așa
în general hari de doi, de opt.
>> Da, pește s a prins, dar nu am prins noi
13 14 15 să prindem așa unut mai mulți.
>> Ok, dar câte rateuri am avut?
>> Au fost și rateuri. Așa e. Rupturi.
Rupturi.
>> Rupturi. Da.
>> Mai mult de 10.
>> Multe.
>> Nu. Mihai are mult. Mihai eu. Și erau
șefat.
Detașat. Da, da. Nu m am hotărât. O să
schimb cârligele. Nu, nu vom menționa pe
cameră, pe filmare cu ce cârlige
pescuiesc. Le voi schimba, voi trece pe
altă pe altă gamă.
Gabi a observat azi la mine o chestie cu
cum port drillul. și mi a făcut
observație.
>> N a fost observație, a futare.
>> O recomandare.
E posibil și asta să fie unul dintre
motive.
Port drillul foarte lung și foarte de
foarte jos și foarte sus. Deci mă duc
după el în apă.
>> Păi așa se normaliza el nu e el nu e de
acord cu chestia asta.
>> El spune că drillul trebuie să fie
scurt.
>> Stai, stai, stai puțin, Harry. Stai
puțin, Hari. Tu nu ai văzut cum face
dinul Mihai? Mihai are lansetele mai
lungi, bagă cotorul de lansetă aici la
subraț și el vine așa. Vine aici cu
lanseta la vârful apei, după care trage,
trage, trage, trage de pește până sus
până duce lanseta pe spate. Deci pe
spate, după care mulinează ei. În
momentul în care el mulinează, atunci el
poate să piardă din tensiunea pe care o
ține în fir. În schimb, dacă faci așa,
un pic sus și ține cotorul lansetei
aici, un pic sus, un pic sus, cum fac
cum fac răparii pe baltă. Depinde,
depinde și și și ce pește este. Adică
mărimea peștelu dește un un pește mic îl
îl faci
>> pe ăla îl faci oricum.
>> Pești ăștia mari mari. Să știi că nu eu
n am nu pot decât să mă duc cu bățul
până în apă.
Și când îl tragi, trebuie să l tragi.
Chestia este că trebuie să trebuie să te
gândești și la mulinetă,
>> că tu când când văd mulți turiști ăia
fac așa.
>> Na,
>> îți dai seama, toată forța intră în în
angrenaj.
>> Tu trebuie să l ajuți. Adică la crap se
spun și toți specialiștii, adică te duci
cu bățul în jos,
tragi, mulinez.
tragi mulinez.
>> Ei, el spune că ăsta cursa asta a mea e
prea e prea lungă.
>> Poate că poate că și bățul e prea lung
și așa. Adică când îl tragi îl tragi
2 3 m sau 4 m dintr un
>> Da. Este un cumul de factor Mihai
Pescușe și cu plumi grei. Plumbul greu
atârnă în fața atârnă în fața în fața
peșel și scoate cârligul din scoate. Și
dacă nu l ții mereu în tensiune, adică
să ai control pe tensiune, e posibil
dacă tu îi dai drumul mai mult și cârli
și plumbul ajunge să se ducă în jos.
>> Și de asta i am zis, bă, aici s ar putea
să nu ai un control atât de mult când
aduce Iisus. Dar v am spus oată cu cu
chestia aia și cred că poate că o faceți
într o zi testul ăla, adică
iei firul cu cârlig și te duci la 100
100 sau așa metri și îi spui să dee
înțepătura. N o să ajungă forța care dă
>> în băț la cârl. Ajunge.
>> Ideea e că eu am randament. Chestia
este, nu, nu știu dacă ați observat, eu
stau în spatele bărcii. Eu până ajung la
la
băț, adică bățul dă înțepătura.
>> Da.
>> Eu singur ce fac? Îl iau de pe ștant și
încep să mulinesc.
>> Așa fac și eu. Eu nu i dau începătură.
Ăă
adică când când n ai randament și ai
prima trăsătură, ești emoționat, stai
acolo și când când a luat o ai dat deja
înțepătura.
Când măâncă bine nu i o problemă, dar eu
astăzi cred că doi sau trei au fost
prinși aici
>> în lateral. Lateral.
>> Lateral.
>> Și eu am avut și noi tot în lateral am
avut. Da,
>> în lateral înseamnă că astăzi n a mâncat
>> n a fost nici vânt. Trebuie să spus
vântul e un factor extraordinar.
>> E Ideea e că eu am vederea de ansamblu,
dar nu sunt atent la detalii și faptul
că nu sunt atent la detalii mă face în
continuare să am un randament sub 50%
>> de pește scos în minci. Și asta asta
trebuie este și de gândit, înțelegi?
Adică ăă dacă ăă aș aș ă
m aș gândi ce ce greșesc, adică m aș
duce de la cârlig până ăsta ăsta, adică
boilisul e bun, peștele mâncat.
>> E clar trăsături avem. Avem trăsături cu
nem adică îi place.
>> Cârligul. Cârligul.
Cred că câ cărligul este a și o
că ai văzut tu ai schimbat după aceea pe
LEDc.
>> Nu, nu pe pe fluorocarbon. Pe fluoroc
>> fluorocarbon. În germană se spune lec.
A, ok.
>> Da. Și și n ai avut rezultate mai bune
ca alții care au rămas numai pe pe
textil. Adică să spui că este
>> a influențat foarte mult. Da.
>> Bine, treaba e când faci testul de genul
ăsta trebuie să schimbi un singur
parametru. Și voi știți mai bine că
sunteți ingineri. Mai devreme am zis că
sunt doi ingineri aici, dar de fapt și
Harry e tot inginer. Am uitat de el.
>> Bine, eu s în pensie
>> sau a fost inginer, dar încă e.
Oricum a fost din punctul meu de vedere
o partidă reușită. Nu am prins ce ne am
dorit, dar a fost super reușită.
>> Ăă
este reușită în punctul de vedere că s a
făcut o prietenie, adică
sper că vom mai face niște partide în
afară de colegul care o să ne părăsească
vreo 10 ani că are bucuria
că vine barza.
>> Corect. Corect. și are alte
>> priorități.
>> Priorități.
>> Se schimbă prioritățile. Vinde barca.
Dacă vreți, s o barcă. Bețe bune.
Nu
>> că e e deja Gabriel. Avem și ve
>> avem și o trăsătură live.
>> Da,
s a mișcat un pic așa.
>> Da.
>> Uite cârcotaș.
Avem condiții foarte grele, 40°
țânțari astea. Păi, numai la
>> dușuri cu apă din Dunăre,
>> apă din Dunăre și așa. Adică na, asta ne
place și asta ne o dorim. Adică da și
una să știți, cu cât sunteți mai
chinuiți, cu atât prindeți mai mult
pește.
>> Corect. Corect. Da, dacă te pregătești
prea bine cu totul țiplă,
>> n o să prinzi.
>> Nu.
>> Băi, deci de fiecare așa s a întâmplat
mereu când am plecat
cu totul perfect, când ești nepregătit
atunci ai cele mai bune partide. Vam cu
ocazia asta să i mai mulțumim și
domnului Răsoiu
>> care ne a
domnului Steelea care ne a au venit
ieri. Ieri au venit încoace și ne au
adus
>> ne au adus după lista de cumpărături
>> ne au adus niște mâncare și cel mai
important patru beri reci.
>> Spune mi spune mi
>> și berele astea pe care vi le am adus eu
de la Crișan astăzi alea,
>> alea s au uitat. Alea au fost acolo și
altele.
>> Hai, mă, că am zis de pastramă, de toate
alea, de pa berile alea re și de la tine
și de la hari
>> câț cârnați de de deșhoi
>> originale că sunt mulți care fac.
>> Auzi, gata că după aia noi tocmai ce am
zis că o ducem rău în deltă.
Vreiam Eu l am amintit l am amintit pe
domnul Răsoiu pentru că astăzi la ora
1:30 când noi eram la masă a prins un
exemplar frumos de aproximativ 18 kg.
>> Da,
>> vi l am vi l am arătat.
>> Deci superb,
>> superb, superb, superb.
>> Și domnul Răsăoiu mi a zis Mihai și am
văzut și eu pe apă este cam printre
singurii care se se ancorează cu
cabinata în curent.
în curent, ceea ce
necesită muncă depune un efort
extraordinar să se ancoreze cu cabinata,
dar rezultatele
>> vin
>> cu muncă
un pic mai multă vin. Vin.
>> Băi, dacă muncești te e și răsplătit.
Dacă te vii, pa pa.
Trebuie să te gândești numai astăzi de
câte ori m am dezancorat și m am
ancorat.
>> Scoate Scoate ancora. Bagă ancora și
vorbim de două
și curent și ăsta și asta, adică și
căldură.
>> Da,
>> păi curgeau apele de pe noi.
Era un pescuit extrem.
>> Da, da,
>> da. Azi ultima dată când ne am ancurat
aici în cioată, Gabi avea trăsături, eu
n aveam. Și eu îi zic: „Mă Gabi, eu cred
eu cred că eu nu sunt bine aice pe
stânga. Păi da, știu că nu ești bine.
Păi și de ce nu
de ce nu zici nimic? Păi am zis să nu să
nu zic că că te superi pe mine că iar
trebuie să ne iar trebuie să scoatem
ancora. Iar
>> a de întâlnit că el e matelotul. Nu, eu
Deci fii atent ca să înțelegeți, ca să
înțelegeți, eu am învățat o regulă
foarte importantă când am făcut școala
de navigator.
>> Căpitanul,
bă, e șeful pe barcă. Trebuie să asculți
de căpitan. Ce zice căpitanul? Aia faci.
Uite, băi, chiar dacă este o barcă de 6
m, de 5,50 m. Da, bă asculți de căpitan.
Dacă căpitanul zice să dai drumul la
ancor, dai drumul lac. Corect.
>> Corect.
>> Dai drumul la ancor și asta.
>> Și unde te duce curentul?
>> E treaba ta.
>> E treaba ta. S abordat fiecare parte a
lui. Adică așa
>> normal, normal.
>> Eu eu îl întrebam pe Gabi, mă, ți ai
luat reper ți ai luat reperul unde i,
mă? Ciata după mal, mă Mihai, nu nu eu
nu nu mi nu mă nu mi am lu arătat așa
reper bine. Și eu eu ne am ancorat, eu
aruncam și Gabi făcea: Păi unde dai, mă,
tu? Păi unde dau? Dau dau în cio acolo.
>> Dau peste cio pe unde, mă, că tu dai
peste cioată. Eu eu da Păi ceată e
acolo. Uite la la tufa nu știu care tufa
a treia nu știu ce. Păi n ai zis bă că
tu nu ți ai luat că tu nu ți iei reper
bine.
>> Eu i am zis uită te tu de reper că eu nu
le am cu reperele. Dar eu când îmi iau
reper, bă eu îmi iau reper pentru că eu
le uit și când îmi iau reper îmi iau tot
ce e pe mal, conformația malului.
Ce culoare are pomul? Ia iau reper la și
la aruncare,
adică îmi caut. Ă am
am fost într un an am cunoscut în Belgia
unde era cel mai mare târg de crap,
boiluri și erau pe timpul orările alea
au fost ok la preț și așa am întâlnit de
un austriac și l am adus în deltă
o săptămână stat de aicea ăla își făcea
desen.
cu structura pomilor. Așa zice mai de la
obrize. El arunca arunca acolo și punea
pe pom primul băț, al doilea băț, al
treilea băț și unde avea rezultate cele
mai bune, noi în ziua de aia aia am
prins foarte mult crap, adică extrem
mult, dar nu depășeam 7 kg
și austriacul a eliberat totul și î
aveam gazda în barcă.
Ăla plângea. Plângea. Dar nu poți. Dar
băi ăsta austriacul zicea dar eu nu pot
să l țin. Ăla nu poți să l arunci. Mă
bară unul, măi. Unul să l avem de
mâncare de seară să așa. Nimica. Deseară
cumpărăm un crap.
Aia a fost prima mea aventură cu
austriacul din Viena.
>> Da. Mai avem persoane pe aici care fac
schițe?
>> Facem, facem și eu. Și eu făceam. Fac
schițe pe mal cu configurația și cu
copacii și funcționează. Chiar
funcționează.
>> E mare lucru să înțelegi locul de
pescuit.
>> Da. Și
>> chestia este chestia este și cu
configurația asta, adică depinde și
debitul apei că și plumbul. Da,
>> dacă ai un plumb mai ușor, cum am venit
eu aice cu 90, am zis ajunge la cotele
astea, ajunge.
>> Dădeam noi plum de 150, dar se rup
lansetele alea gen mina.
>> Hai mă, hai, mă, hai, mă, să povestim
tot, mă, cum
>> Hai mă, să povestim tot, mă.
>> Deci Deci vine Harry să pescuiască pe
Navig Gabi
>> și se trage la mal. Și ce lansete s
alea, Hari? E germină.
Nu știu ce. A ne punem pe locul de
pescuit și începe Harry să lanseze și
vine primul pește. Bă, era germina
cobrig. Uite așa era germina făcută și
noi râdeam că eram în barcă lângă barcă.
Ia uite Hari cu germina ce se chinuie
și scoate unul de șapte.
>> Scoate unul de șapte și era Harry.
>> Noi mergem cu lansete un pic mai
puternice pe
>> Cred că putem să adăugăm pe video.
>> Ce? Lansetele
>> așa măcar o sec. Ț din drill. Din drill
a. Se vedea cum se făcea
>> cum se făcea germina.
>> Da.
>> A,
>> am eu un video.
>> Păi am și eu. Hai îmi trimiți și tu și
pune. Pun. Deci punem să vedeți cum se
cum se face cum se face germina pe
>> c
>> pe alea le cumpăr eu.
>> Sunt Sunt cu sic.
Adică totul numai cotorul, adică ăsta
blancul îm
a rămas germinat, dar este un Da.
Adică ați ați observat prinde pește că
nu l nu l
>> nu l simte.
>> Nu l simte.
>> Da, da, da, da.
>> Dar la drill face cu tine ce vrea el. El
ducă ce vrea.
>> Am văzut eu era Harry când pe partea
aia. Când pe partea aia. Uite,
zici că zici că dea cu lansetă de
feeder. Știi?
>> Eu sunt de părere că
odată cu experiența în timp
apreciez mai mult senzațiile tale.
>> Da.
>> Și Hari eu zic că i cu senzațiile tare
aici.
>> Da, da. Așa este. Așa este. Deci eu la
feeder dau cu niște feedere parabolice.
Dădeam prima oară când m am apucat de
feder dădeam cu feedere parabolice, alea
care se îndoaie ca germină. Bă, o
frumusețe drillul și după care hai să
fim și noi mai profesioniști, mai alea
mai nu știu ce, alea mai scump. Chestia
este chestia este Forgodorin a fost
primul,
>> trebuie să recunosc, care
toată lumea care venea în deltă venea cu
par.
>> Da. pe co pe s a făcut concurs de crap,
nu știu dacă știți,
cupa
>> Big Fish.
>> Big Fish. Big Fish.
>> Da.
>> Și a venit din toată România. A venit
acolo.
Când i am văzut pe băieți cu bețe de
380,
cu așa, am știut că câștig concursul.
Am știut din start că câștig. Nu din
cauză că știam că peștele mânca foarte
sensibil, adică ăă dacă simțea parii ăia
în sculpat și
după aceea s o stabilizit, adică
să dai la feeder la crap. Adică după
aceea au ajuns trabuco, care au un gamă
largă,
>> o gamă largă care vorba aia în față e
foarte flexibil și după aceea cotorul
>> Da. E puternic ține ține peștele. Dar vă
spun lumea a crezut că vine în deltă
aicea cu 380. Îți dai seama? Păi când
plesneau odată, păi ce pește p b.
>> Eu eram obișnuit cu finețe. Dădeam cu
îți dai seama, aproape feeder din ăstea
de de de ca de știucă.
>> Da, da, da.
>> Sau de de de biban. Și aveam plumb de 60
>> și ei dădeau cu cu trei lipsi, patru
lipsi, că erau veneau de la de la
Giurgiu, de la unde trebuia să lansez
departe și așa. Păi da,
>> dar pescuitul în deltă și pescuitul pe
canale e total diferit.
Și era unul din Bacău care se făceau
pariu la Adică la un concurs se mai faci
și pariuri. Nu știu dacă știți.
>> Da, la a la concurs da se făceau cine
câștigă și adică între prieteni așa.
Adică
asta ăsta ăsta ăsta
>> și era unul din Bacău care o o
dat banii pe mine și eram echipă cu
Dorin Forgo, știi? Și noi am și
câștigat. Ei au ajuns pe locul doi
că au schimbat și el stilul. După aceea
mers pe feeder, a prins crap mărunt, dar
mult
>> mult. Uite acuma că deschidem așa cutia
Pandorei
fiecare are credințele lui din
perspectiva asta în pescuit. 10 pescința
sau e experiență.
>> Exact. 10 pescari. Dacă pui 10 pescari
la masă, 10 pescari au păreri diferite
despre lucrul acesta, despre culoare și
despre aromă.
>> Da,
>> eu unul personal,
>> dar ce ce este așa, adică la temperaturi
de 30° merg boiliser pe ulei, pe
temperatur când scade sub 10° merge pe
bază de
din astea cum se spune
>> esterii.
>> Da. Adică țuică și așa
>> solubilitate și tari ca să ca așa
solubilitate și tari. Exact ce noi în
gama GDA FIC încercăm să facem. Cireașa
de pe tort pe care ai pescuit cu ea și
ai văzut
>> ce se întâmplă cu ea este pentru
perioada în care ai nevoie de
solubilitate, perioada de toamnă, iarnă
și chiar și
>> este este b bine. Ianuarie, februarie,
martie până
trec de 20°. Exact.
>> După aceea se topesc foarte repede și
atunce Da.
>> Pescuind la feeder, eu consider că și
atunce pot fi folosite dacă tu scoți
feederul la un sfert de oră
>> la caras. Da.
>> Dacă dacă ești pe canal dacă ești pe
canal și cauți activitate, activitatea
ți o aduce ți o aduce bila. Bila
solubilă.
>> Noi cum am pescuit acum cu bilele cu
rețeta lui Mihai, este bilă tare,
>> da? care îți aduce
în ghilimele, să zic trofee. Da? Adică
nu ți aduce o activitate, nu ți aduce o
rapiditate, ci îți aduce pești mai mari.
Poți să stai mai mult pe trăsătură, ai
bila mai mult în apă, ceea ce cireașa de
pe nu ți oferă asta și de asta este
recomandată în sezonul rece. Și
bineînțeles vara dacă vrei să ai
activitate, te ai dus pe canale și vrei
să prinzi rapinzi pește, asta faci. Că
noi dacă stăteam pe rapiditate,
>> neapărat pe canale
>> și pe navigabil și pe navigabil doar că
trebuie să schimbi la 15 minute.
>> Adică dacă ești un pescar activ
>> e o muncă grea. E o muncă grea, dar o să
s ar putea să prinzi mai mult
>> binețeles
>> decât cel care stă pe bilet și
cantitatea
>> după după ce temperatura apei scade la
>> 6°
dau un randament extraordinar.
>> Da. Pe canale în deltă na. Eu eu am o
vorbă. Bă, cireașa de pe tort dacă o
folosești cum trebuie, băgată în
momitor, cum o fac eu, frumos, cu nada
pe momitor, n are cum rezultate? Am avut
și eu rezultate.
>> N are cum. Deci eu am zis, bă, dacă e
peștele acolo, n are cum să i reziști.
>> Păi dacă înseamnă că nu i acolo.
>> Exact. Nu i acolo. Nu. Și noi știm că i
acolo. Îl găsim,
>> îl vedem.
>> Așa este. Da.
Da.
O mi a plăcut expediția asta.
Chiar a fost o expediție. Chiar pot să
zic că a fost o expediție cu plimbat, cu
>> A fost o expediție. A fost ar fi plăcut
să închidem cu un trofeu.
>> Cu un trofeu.
>> Mâine mai avem încă cinci 6 ore de pe
>> Eu dacă ne culcăm și noi acuma că e
12:00 noaptea.
>> E stăm un pic,
>> mai facem o rundă și gata.
>> Da, mai stăm un pic. Uite, mai punem un
paha
>> că ca ultima noapte. Ce vorba aia?
>> Bă, dacă intră peștele, intră și într o
oră. Așa tineri ca în seara asta. N o să
mai filmăm niciodată când ne mai
întâlnim o dată.
>> Corect. Mâine avem o zi.
>> Mie îmi pare bine că l am cunoscut pe
Mihai.
Pe Gabi își Ne am întâlnit în primăvară.
>> Da.
>> El
mi a dat telefon. Hai, Harry. Hai aice.
Uite, vezi că așa și așa. Eu căutam
peștele.
>> Da, da, da. Încă nu apăruse pe canal.
>> Da.
Cu Cosmin te ai găsit în domeniul auto
amândoi la tu la Mercedes el la Renault
>> cu Hari m am cunoscut pe canal pe
>> pe Dunărea Veche pe Îustă ne mai întâln
Ne am mai întâlnit noi o dată
>> pe Șontea.
>> Am discutat așa un pic pe Șonte. Ai
prins ceva? N ai prins? Și de atunci eu
am ținut minte și după aia ne am
întâlnit îngustă și am stat de vorbă. Eu
prinsesem un pește, după care era pauză
și vine Hari: Salut! Salut! Ai prins
ceva? S a tras lângă mine la barcă. Am
stat de vorbă jumătate de oră și după
aia am schimbat numărul și am vorbit pe
WhatsApp. Uite, am prins aici. Uite aice
peștele. Uite, uite. Nu, așa se fac
prieteniile. În Delta Dunării te
împrietenești cu mulți oameni și câți
prieteni nu ne am făcut în Delta
Dunării.
Și ăsta este unul dintre motivele pentru
care locurile în Delta Dunării pe care
prinzi pește nu se dau atât de ușor și
mulți nu înțeleg. Mulți nu înțeleg.
>> Nu, pești Adică
>> din punctul meu de vedere nici n ar
trebui să întrebi.
>> Da, da, așa e. Nu, nu trebuie să întreb
>> că este o muncă foarte intensivă. Este
foarte ce nu știu mulți și costisitoare
>> benzină, boiluri de calitate care arunci
poate cât degeaba înăuntru
>> 3 4 kg
>> și
nopți nedormite.
>> Întreb, deci cred că ar trebui să ți
permiți să întrebi în ce loc ai dat
decât între prieteni foarte foarte
apropiați.
>> Da. Nu,
>> căruia și tu la un moment dat i ai
oferit,
>> adică
>> experiența ta, adică împarți experiența.
Dacă tu depui muncă cu mine, tu te duci
pe, nu știu, pe canale și eu sunt pe
navigabil și tu mi zici uite se prinde
pește acolo, hai să pescuim împreună și
invers, atunci mi se pare OK. Dar că nu
ai nicio nu știu, nu i oferi nimic de de
prins că se prinde pe navigabil sau în
zona cutare sau în zona cutare pe mine
nu mă deranjează. Deci chiar nu mă
deranjează. Asta e ok. Da, domnule,
merge acolo, merge pe navigat,
>> merge pe Sulina, merge pe Sud Gheorghe,
merge pe Chilia, dar
la ce milă, la ce cioată, la
[Muzică]
ce grad? 45°
am un Nu pot să spun coleg sau așa. Păi,
atâta mă întreabă până la urmă. zic, nu
vrei să spui și gradul
bărcii, înțelegi? Adică,
>> dar uite, hai să mai clarificăm chestia
asta pentru că noi știm chestia asta. În
momentul în care găsești un loc, te
chinui să cauți un loc și găsești un loc
unde ai localizat peștele și începi să
prinzi pește. Dacă apar trei, patru,
cinci bărci după tine
>> cu gălăgie,
>> cu lansări,
>> dar nu cu gălăgie, nu fără gălăgie,
>> cu lansări, cu fire în apă, cu pus
cabinate care își lasă jos ancora.
Începe să nu se mai prindă pește. Și ni
s a întâmplat de multe ori chestia asta,
să se taie peștele. Mie mi s a întâmplat
să postez clipuri pe TikTok și pe alte
canale. Eram pe un gustă. Bă, am văzut
cum veneau cabinatele și și la un moment
dat o cabinată, nu știu dacă se uită la
clipul ăsta
>> pe mine. Știi ce mă enervează?
>> Se pune lângă tine, mă.
>> Nu. Chestia este nu numai că se pune
lângă tine, începe momul. Vum vum vum
vum. Și eu stau acolo, înțelegi?
După aceea îmi strică locul, că eu nu
știu ce boiler îmi dă. Da.
>> Da. Dar aruncând el momeală, că știu,
majoritatea dau cu Decathlon.
>> Da.
>> Poate să fie căpșunică, poate să fie
Monster Crab, poate să fie Scopex așa,
dar chestia este atunce o oră, două
>> nu mai
>> nu mai o trăsătură.
>> Așa e. Păi, îți dai seama, eu
nu ți am zis acolo unde am pescuit noi
doi, nu vreau să ți dau detalii acuma. A
venit unul cu porumb.
Băi, în fața mea a început. Vă Ce faci,
domnule? Eu dau acolo. Păi, tu stai în
partea asta. Da, domnule, dar dau în
partea asta. Păi, de ce nu stai aicea?
Păi,
>> te ia și la Te ia și la R. Băi, e este
așa lung canalul, nu aicea? Că s a uitat
pe sonar, s o pus acolo și a început cu
porumbul. Păi, îți dai seama că mi a
stricat ziua de pescuit. Seama nu, nu.
Așa e, așa e. Eu dacă am un loc favorit,
îl nădesc și merg la pensiune și vin a
doua zi, dar nu că vin a doua zi și când
mă duc direct acolo pe el și e locul meu
favorit, când văd pe cineva acolo, mi se
face mi se face rău.
Deci efectiv trebuie să trag aer în
piept. Așa.
>> Da, mă. Nu, bă, nu i o problemă. Chestia
este chestia e următoarea cu pe timpuri
nu știa nimeni, trecea peste locul tău,
dar tuind să zicem 5 6 10 kg de boilies
acolo
tu până te învârți la o cafea în
pensiune și așa trece timpul când te
întorci că spui că locul tău e liber
vine unul cu sonarul și vede că crab
acolo.
>> Da. Se pune acolo, îți strică ziua,
>> ai venit până acolo, trebuie să cauți
altă cioată, trebuie să începi să
momești iarăși. De aia e bine să aveți
două trei locuri.
>> Asta voiam să spun că am am mai am mai
îmbătrânit și eu puțin și am ajuns la
concluzia
>> să ai să ai să ai
>> Deci tu câte locuri ai înădit când te ai
dus acuma? Pe două sau trei? trei
>> trei locuri. Deci se întâmpla ceva pe
unu. Voi mai avea două rezerve.
>> Exact. Exact.
>> Din toate din toate trei locurile două
mi s a ocupat.
>> Exact. Uite. Poftim. Așa e.
>> Da, dar asta înseamnă consum de
de boiless uri, de energie, benzină,
benzină, de tot, tot timp.
>> Na.
>> Și nervi. Nervi.
>> Așa e. Ca și concluzie, dacă vedeți o
poză cu cineva sau zice bă prind pe
canalul Olgut, de exemplu și vedeți care
e barca aia, bă, nu vă puneți lângă el,
nu fix lângă el.
>> Pentru că peștele e pe tot canalul.
>> Trebuie trebuie să să catalighizăm.
Sunt oameni care merg pe trofee, adică
pe
așa și sunt oameni care merg pe
cantitate pentru mâncare, înțelegi? Și
oamenii ăștia niciodată, niciodată n o
să meargă, n o să muncească. Ei vin tot
pe roadele
>> altora.
>> Te pup.
>> Hai, noapte bună.
Și
erau 60 la oră.
Nimeni nu mergea la pescuit și erau
niște pescari de știuc care plecau spre
Din cauza vântului au luat o spre
Dunavăț
pe pe canale să ajungă la Tulcea și eu m
am luat după ei și am plecat pe un
canal. Eram singur acolo.
Vântul bătea așa tare și rece. De stuful
era jos.
Băi, și am prins și am prins.
Nu făceam față cu două bețe. Îți dai
seama?
>> Da, da, da.
>> Și aia atunce uiți de frig, uiți de
vânt, uiți de ploaie, uiți de tot. Eu am
o experiență Am o experiență de genul
ăsta
>> la Marian la GFT la primit de membrilor.
Am fost prima zi nu s a prins pește
adică mă rog 1 2 3 pe colo. Nu, nimeni
nu găsește peștele. Nu era pește pe mine
la 23 și a doua zi ploaie. Dar nu că
ploaie, de la 5:00 dimineața a plouat
torențial.
>> Da, a plouat toată ziua
>> torențial. Torențial. Eu eram cu Marius.
>> Noi n avem barcă închisă, avem barcă
deschisă. Când ne am uitat pe geam că
plouă, eu i am zis Marius, bă, mergem la
pește. Marius a zis, merg și eu, nu i
problemă, mergem la pește. Ne am luat
bine pe noi, ne am îmbrăcat, am plecat
la pește, ne am pe drum ne am întâlnit
cu Mihai, care era frumos cu cu
>> cu Biminiul. Tu știi că este o vorbă
germană, nu există vreme ea.
>> Da.
>> Numai haine proaste.
>> Exact, exact. Ei, și de atunci am plecat
pe canal și am început să să căutăm
peștele. Deci a fost o partidă una
dintre cele mai frumoase din viața mea
pentru că ce condițiile erau atât de
nasoale. Deci, bă, a plouat încontinuu.
Încontinuu a plouat. Deci aveam trei
brichete la noi. Toate trei erau ude,
>> nu mai aveam să aprindem. Deci Marius e
mai greu decât mine. Stătea pe capul
bărcii și toată apa se strângea acolo.
Din când în când îl chemam în spate ca
să dăm drumul la pompa în santină să
scoatem apa din barcă. Norocul nostru că
la un moment dat a trecut Scârlătescu pe
canal și dă ne și nouă o brichetă că nu
mai aveam să ne aprindem. Deci eram uz
loarcă. Uzi loarcă. Dar a fost o
partidă. Deci am prins pești atunci. E
astea s memorabile.
>> Da.
>> Și nimeni bine nimeni. Cei care aveau
cabinete și așa pescuiau, dar noi am
ieșit la pescuit. Și noi am pescuit bine
în cu bimini și cu Am avut toate
condițiile, dar n am n am prins bine.
Noi am luat tot așa doi ciortani, dar tu
ai luat ai luat mai bine ca noi că te ai
dus pe pe luat am luat și la 6 kg.
>> Noi noi ne am încăpățânat să rămânem pe
apa adâncă acolo pe mila 23.
Costin făcea Cosmin făcea Ți am zis că
nu e de pescuit la crap, că trebuia să
mergem la șalău direct. Nu stăm aice.
Stăm aice la crap, că nu e de pescuit la
crap.
>> Știi? Unde am fost eu? Pe Bogda Prost.
>> Așa. Pe Bogda Prost. Pe Bogda Prost. Bă,
deci l am găsit acolo.
Am făcut o experiență pe boda Prastii.
Așa ceva n am văzut în viața mea.
Am mers la boda prostii
de sus până jos
și acolo pe insulița aia acolo la ieșire
erau o tabără.
Și am întrebat care i treaba. Merge
peștele și a tras
>> la ieșirea în lac sau la ieșirea înspre
Dunărea vech Dunărea veche. În Dunărea
Veche, acolo pe partea stângă cum cobori
este loc.
>> Eram cu un prieten din Germania.
Am luat o în sus.
Am luat o în sus și
măi atâta bule.
N am văzut din viața mea. Am zis și este
vorbim de 10 m.
Ăia erau în față, n au avut o trăsătură.
Eu 10 m în spate,
păi am luat la pește.
Nu vă pot spune. Și chestia asta mi s a
întâmplat și la roșu. E vorba de 10 m.
>> Da, așa e. 10 m.
>> Așa e. Așa e.
>> 10 m.
>> Și din cauza asta tot spun de aia nu m
am strofocat când am mers noi pe locul
ăla când n am văzut activitate în apă.
Adică bule pa pa pa pa pa.
Că atunce știu că caută.
>> Se hrănește.
>> Se hrănește dimineața
de bucurie sare din apă. Înțelegi?
Atunce știu. E mort.
>> Da.
Și dacă toate toate informațiile astea
se adună, poate că am dreptate, poate că
nu am dreptate, dar din experiența mea
asta mi o mi a zis. Adică dacă nu vezi
bule are, n are rost să pescuiești.
Singurul lucru din punctul ăsta de
vedere unde poți să prinzi pește este
zona de staționare, adică cio
>> când nu vezi bule pe cio
prinzi pe
>> chestia este în toamnă e foarte ușor.
Majoritatea când iasă din pensiune sau
unde dorm sau așa
acolo unde vrea să pescuiască. Băi,
ieșiți afară,
trageți odată pe nări. Azi dimineață
când am tras o dată pe n am simțit
sulful, am știut
>> canci pește.
>> Canci peste la mila 23, înțelegi?
>> Corect. Așa e.
>> Și după aceea când am văzut pescuții și
pe canal
săreau la suprafață
canci oxigen.
>> Exact. Ce vrei să prinzi?
>> Exact așa e.
>> Ce vrei să prinzi?
>> Așa e. Bun. Hai să mergem la somn,
dragilor, asta a fost ultima seară a
noastră. Mâine mai avem încă cinci 6 ore
de pescuit. Sperăm să scoatem ce ne am
dorit, adică pești mai mari de 13 kg.
Mâine vreau să prind eu unul mai mare
decât 13. De 13. Avem un pariu. Avem
Avem un pariu.
>> Avem și un pariu pe 13 plus. O să vedem
dacă î iau sau nu l iau. Ă dacă nu
prindem mâine pește, ciortan, sigur vom
prinde.
>> Asta ne face și mai rău. Să ne gândim la
greșeli. Unde am greșit.
>> Exact. Exact.
>> Când m ați dus acolo sus, am zis:„Cine
dracu m a dus aicea?
Nu puteam să rămân pe lobris.
>> Da, Harry. Dar locul ăla pe toamnă
pentru Erfan a plecat de pe obriz. Erfan
era cu cabinata lângă noi. A mai rămas o
seară acolo, dar a prins pește. Deci
odată când am luat eu pe ăla de 13, au
luat și ei unul de 12. Și cu toate
astea, marți sau miercuri, miercuri au
plecat de pe Obriz și s au mutat
>> pe Erenciuc, pe Sfântul Gheorghe. Deci
au au deja o experiență, au simțit ceva.
Chestia este că prin scăderea asta
bruscă de apă, vorbim de cotă de 30 care
în timpul ăsta a fost niciodată
intră
să sărăței alea. Cred că
>> din obriz 1, obriz 2, obriz 3, până la
obriz 3 urcă sărățara,
>> înțelegi? și peștele urcă sus. La
Sfântul Gheorghe e aceeași problemă, dar
nu i așațată.
>> Pronunțată că
>> Da. Și
nu știu.
>> Deci s au mutat așa și iar azi au avut
niște rezultate
excepționale.
>> Bravo lor, bravo lor.
>> În primul rând e ok să ai un boilist
bun. Corect. Nu zic bun, ci boilist
corect. Da.
Am fost acum doi ani de zile în
>> Eu am semne de întrebare la Decathlon la
prețul care practic am rezerve față de
dacă e un boil corect sau nu hai să nu
discutăm despre asta că nu nu face sens
să zicem ce ce se face și ce nu.
Acum doi ani de zile am fost în Spania.
Da. Pe Ebro, marele Ebro, Pești.
>> Da. Ho! Și mai pusesem încă un an
înainte și prinsesem pește foarte bine.
E, am fost pe Ebro în perioada de
primăvară când pe Ebro depuneau crapi.
Am fost acolo la Christian. Christian
zice: "Pescuim cu asta, asta, asta. Eu
deja știam cu ce se pescuiește. Pelete,
nu știu ce, biletari și așa mai departe.
>> Trei zile n am prins nimic. Bine, nimic.
Prinsesem niște ciortani, da, dar noi
neesem pentru pește mare. N am prins
nimic.
E după trei zile după ce stau eu și zic,
bă, stai un pic, mă. Noi suntem români,
mă. Bă, noi știm mai bine, mă, decât
alții cum să pescuim, că noi știm. La
noi nu e pește. Noi trebuie să păcălim
pește ca să l prindem. Ăia au pește
acolo. Căcălău și cu Deci cu bile. A
venit ăla cu niște bile de alea. Face un
prieten de al meu biletar, nu știu ce.
Bă, nu aveam trăsătură. Și mă uit eu în
trusă. Să nu spui că ai băgat de cador.
>> Mă uit eu în trusă și găsesc niște bile
solubile și pun două pe cârlig, două la
firul de păr. Deci, două bile solubile
de 24 la fir de păr, făcute pătrat.
Deci, practic, aveam un dreptunghi
acolo. Lângă noi era un ungur foarte de
treabă băiatul profesionist cu votpot.
Se ridica așa cu bărcuță de aia
pneumatică de plantat, bă cu două
lansete. Mamă, era profesionist. Noi
aveam șase, ște, opt lansete întinse,
una mai lungă, una mai scurtă, că na.
Și mă uit la mă uit, deci îmi aduc
aminte, eram singur pe locul de pescuit
și mă uit la
>> la ungur
>> la ungur și spun așa: "My friend, secret
bites." Băi, exact așa i am spus, secret
bites. 10 minutes run. A,
bine, nici eu n aveam n știi? Dar aveam
eu așa o vagă impresie și pun bilele
alea, lansez. Bă, nu trec 30 de minute
run 13 kg.
Du te, nu e, nu e posibil așa ce. Pac,
scot aia de acolo, scot peștele. După
care toate lansetele le am făcut așa și
a început pescuitul. Ce se întâmpla?
Peștele, că după aia am stat să analizez
foarte bine și de aice vine chestia cu
solubilitatea. Da, am stat să analizez.
Peștele era la depus. Când este la depus
nu este atât de activ.
>> Nu este activ că se concentrează pe
>> Exact mai mult. El mănâncă, el se
hrănește, dar nu este atât de activele
alea tari, peletele alea mari de le fac
ăia așa cu gaură în mijloc. Și eu cu
solubilitatea mea prindeam pește și
atunci am zis, bă,
am făcut legătura cu decathlonul, de ce
prinde Decatlonul și nu știu ce și nu
știu ce și am văzut că de fapt este
solubilitatea și nu este concentrația
din interior. Și când am făcut cireașa
de pe tort, ăsta a fost primul criteriu
pe lângă ingredientele corecte,
solubilitate.
Și ați văzut ce înseamnă solubilitate.
>> Da, da. Ca și experiență am vrut să
discut.
>> Am prins cu cireașa de pe tort pe apă de
5°.
E Deci în ianuarie am avut o partidă cu
fetițele mele pe apă de 5°. Afară erau
0°.
Unul mai îmbrăcat, mă. Bravo.
Hai.
Ia să vedem. Așa.
>> Poți?
Bine,
asta.
>> Stai puțin.
Aici,
>> dragilor, au început să intre și la noi
peștii mai îmbrăcați.
Este ultima zi de pescuit, de fapt
ultima zi, ultimele câteva ore de
pescuit.
>> Care m e 11 a zis că într o oră, că la
12 plecăm.
sau o întindem până la 1:30. Vedem, mai
stăm un pic în funcție de cum răspunde
peștele acum, dar așa se întâmplă de
multe ori. Pe ultima 100 de m încep să
intre niște pești puțin mai frumușei,
fix când trebuie să plece.
>> Asta e și o recomandare să luptați până
în ultima oră de pescuit.
>> Corect. Hai, fă și o poză.
Poți
Aha. Mai mare, tată. Mai mare. Bravo!
Mai mare ca
ăsta.
>> Da.
Aici
dublu drill și dublă eliberare.
Dragilor,
în minutul 95,
ba chiar aș spune aproape de prelungiri
marcăm două goluri.
>> Marcăm două goluri. Doi crapi unul după
altul. Mihai nu i am cântărit. Mihai a
spus că unul are opt home 5, iar eu am
zis că
>> Da. E și celălalt a spus șase.
>> Nu, nu, nu. tăuia are avea 75 și are
>> iar eu
>> data viitoare, dacă nu mă crede îți spun
îți pun cântarul, dar știi cum am ochiul
format la
marja de eroare la 2 300 de gol.
>> Bun.
Treaba e că am muncit mult partita asta.
Ne am mutat mult cu cortul.
Am făcut
tot felul de artificii, de nădiri, de
mutări, de plecat dricuri
până când am reușit să scoatem ceva mai
mă
>> noi am sperat să scoatem 13 plus, 15
plus, dar mai avem o oră și nu se știe.
>> Cosmin a reușit să să scoată 9.5
>> 9.5
>> Harry zice că a avut un 20 plus.
Nu știm sigur pentru că lansetele lui
sunt foarte foarte moi și cred că și un
10 plus abia îl gâtea și cu alea de pe
rock. Cel trebuie n a n a reușit să l
>> Da, nu l a scos.
>> A avut doi
>> doi doi. Azi a avut două rupturi. Da.
Deci hari a avut azi două rupturi.
Peștele mare este prin zonă. Rămâne doar
să și are fel de 0,40.
>> Da.
Un aers el unul scos, unul a scăpat din
cârlig. De am comandat întotdeauna după
ce scoatem pește sau după ce schimbăm
motura să verificăm
>> cârligul dacă înțapă.
>> Cârle dacă înțeapă sau nu
>> și dacă are forma potrivită mai înțep
lui nu mai înțepă.
>> Deci e clar pește frumos pentru că nu
mai înțepa cârnul.
>> Bun. Ne a crescut un pic motivația
pentru căzuse.
Am încercat să neburăm. Nu ne a ieșit
ancorarea. Mihai se enervase un pic. Eh,
chestii de genul ăsta. Acuma Mihai e
fericit. Ne a crescut un pic moralul.
Dacă mai prindem un pește până plecăm,
suntem super fericiți.
>> Cireașa.
>> Cireașa de pe Da,
>> bă. Deci nu. Deci fii atent. Este 12:59
și am zis că la ora 1:00
pune mâna pe lansete și strânge la 12:59
run. Dar ai văzut ce frumos a lăsat pe
ea? Da, da, da, da, da.
Frumos, frumos.
Ia uite l, ne pregăteam să plecăm și îi
facem poze și o luăm spre casă. Hai!
[Muzică]
Zici că a făcut podul pe spate. Așa
tras. Ia ia. Uită te la el. Zici că face
podul pe spate. De la alea.
>> Nu, nimic. Nu.
>> Cât pot, mă. H